MY APOLOGIES FOR THE DELAY.
HAPPY VALENTINE'S HAPPY- IN
MEXICO WITH A HAPPY DAY OF
FRIENDSHIP. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE BEFORE I BEGAN I WANT I
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE.
FOLLOWING FOR PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THE DISCUSSION. TODAY WE ARE
HAVING AN IN PERSON HEARING IN
THE STATE CAPITOL IN ROOM FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN. THE PANELISTS ON
THE AGENDA ARE PARA MULTI USING
ONLINE TECHNOLOGY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WILL WE WILL BEGIN WITH
THOSE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
FOLLOWED BY PHONE TESTIMONY.
EACH PERSON WILL HAVE. ONE
MINUTE SPEAK ONLY ONE MINUTE THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT THIS AND
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD
BE ALSO ON THE SCREEN OF YOUR
STREAMING THIS HEARING. JUST IN
CASE THE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S.
877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT US ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2099 AND A
STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU.
WILL NOT BE TAKING ANY VOTES
TODAY. THE FOR PROFIT. OKAY WE
WILL NOT BE TAKING THE VOTES
TODAY BUT I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. GARCIA HERE
JONES SAWYER LACKEY HERE STONE
YOUR WIDER IF. THANK YOU TO THEY
WILL BE DISCUSSING BUDGET
PROPOSAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL. ALSO I IN
ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE OUR-
PANELISTS TIME- AND I APPRECIATE
THE FLEXIBILITY WE'RE GONNA
START WITH ISSUE ONE BUT THEN
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE.
THREE AFTER ISSUE ONE ON THE
AGENDA AND SO I APPRECIATE
PEOPLE FLEXIBILITY TODAY WITH
THAT. DO WE HVE THE PANELISTS
READY FOR ISSUE ONE WHICH IS-
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION. REVISED THE
LATEST PRISON POPULATION
PROJECTIONS FOR THE STATE PRISON
WE HAVE CHRIS CHAMBERS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OFFICE
RESEARCH AND CAITLIN O'NEILL
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICE OF.
ANALYST OFFICE AND IT WE DO HAVE
THE APARTMENT OF FINANCES
AVAIABLE FOR QUESTIONS FROM THE
SUB COMMITTEE BUT THEY WILL NOT
BE PRESENTING ON THIS ISSUE RICK
A PRIEST- HAVE THE PALACE BEGAN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR IN
ORDER TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRIS CHAMBERS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR C. SARS OFFICER
RESEARCH. HAS TO PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
CCAR'S FALL TWENTY TWENTY ONE
POPULATION PROJECTIONS. CCAR'S
FALL POPULATION PROJECTIONS
UTILIZED TO STORE TREND DATA
INCLUDING DELCOURT COMMITMENTS
IN INTAKE TO STATE PRISON TO
PREDICT FUTURE POPULATIONS. CDCR
SPOKE REJECTIONS THEY ARE
UTILIZED ARE CUT OFF AS OF JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN
ORDER TO PREPARE THE PROJECTIONS
. YOU CANNOT HAS BEEN PROVIDED
TO YOU WHICH INCLUDES OUR
CURRENT POPULATION PROJECTIONS
COMPARED TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT PROJECTIONS FOR
REFERENCE. YOU'RE LOOKING AT.
INSTITUTIONAL POPULATION ALL
TWENTY ONE POPULATION
PROJECTIONS ANTICIPATE THE
AVERAGE DAILY INSTITUTIONAL
POPULATION WOULD BE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED AND
FOUR THOUSAND. FIVE HUNDRED FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND 1-001-200-0900
AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. OUR
CURRENT ADULT INMATE POPULATION
AS OF FEBRUARY THIRTEENTH. IS
APPROXIMATELY JUST UNDER. NINETY
SIX THOUSAND. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
POPULATION PROJECTIONS INCLUDE
ESTIMATED IMPACTS FOR EXPANDED
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR ELDERLY
PAROLE PROGRAM IN THE NONVIOLENT
PAROLE PROCESS THAT WERE NOT
PREVIOUSLY INCLUDED. BUDGET
THIRTIETH KHALAF OF DATA
UTILIZED TO CALCULATE FALL
TWENTY ONE PROJECTIONS SEVERAL
ADJUSTMENTS WILL BE INCORPORATED
INTO OUR SPRING TWENTY TWENTY
TWO PROJECTIONS THE MAY REVISION
WILL INCORPORATE DATA ENTRANCE
THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF
THE YEAR AS WELL AS THE
FOLLOWING ADJUSTMENTS. BASED
UPON ACTUAL LEVEL OF INTAKE
BETWEEN JULY AND DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CDCR DID NOT
RECEIVE AS MANY ADMISSIONS AS WE
PREVIOUSLY ANTICIPATED. AND AS
SUCH THERE WILLBE A DOWNWARD
ADJUSTMENT TO SPRING POPULATION
PROJECTIONS. WE WILL ALSO ADJUST%
THE ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT WHEN WE
WILL REACH NORMAL LEVELS AND
THEN TAKE YOU TO RECEPTION
CENTERS. ARE YOU. REGISTERED TO
PERCEPTION CENTER STREET ON THE
CONTRARY. THE FALL TWENTY ONE
PROJECTIONS THAT ASSUMED INTAKE
TO RECEPTION CENTERS WITH
STABILIZER CREEK AND THE
MCCORKLE'S. BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND REMAIN AT THOSE
LEVELS THROUGHOUT THE PROJECTION
CYCLE. IN ADDITION I WILL ALSO
BE INCORPORATING THE ESTIMATED
IMPACT OF SENATE BILL FORTY
THREE. WHICH WAS PASSED AFTER WE
COMPLETED OUR PROJECTIONS. WHEN
WE LOOK AT PEARL POPULATION
CEASAR EXPECTS ACTED PRO
POPULATION WILL DECREASE IN THE
AVERAGE DAILY PEARL POPULATION.
WILL BE PROJECTED TO
APPROXIMATELY FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. AND FORTY TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. THE
ANTICIPATED DECREASE SOME PRO
POPULATION IS RELATED TO CHANGES
DUE TO EARN DISCHARGE AS WELL AS
LENGTH OF PAROLE TERMS FOR MOST
PAROLEES. IT WENT INTO EFFECT
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. THE
POLLING CHANGE ALLOWS MOST NON
SEX REGISTRANT DETERMINEDLY
SENTENCE PAROLEES RELEASED FROM
PRISON. AFTER JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY CONSERVING TO YOUR
PRO. APPROPRIATE THREE YEARS FOR
MOST PROBABLY SPENT AN
INDETERMINATE SENTENCE. IN
LOOKING AT OUR JUVENILE
POPULATION CITIES ARE PROJECTS
TO TOTAL JUVENILE AVERAGE DAILY
POPULATION LIKE SEVEN EIGHT TEN
POINT 7% DECREASE FROM JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND REACH SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN YEARS BY JUNE
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND THEN
FURTHER DECREASED. TWENTY POINT
2% TO REACH FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
THREE YEARS. BY JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE NOW THAT IS AN
AVERAGE DAILY POPULATION NUMBER
NOT THE ACTUAL POPULATION
NUMBER. THAT WE WOULD SEE AND-
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE. IT
IS PROJECTED DECLINE REFLECTS
ANTICIPATED CHANGES- ACID
JUBILATION OF JUVENILE JUSTICES
REALIGNED INTO OUR LOCAL
SYSTEMS. ALSO DUE TO THIS CHANGE
THE PROJECTIONS ASSUMED NO
ADDITIONAL YOUTH WOULD BE
RECEIVED AFTER DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST. OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THAT CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW YEAH
I'M OPEN FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT PANELIST. KEEP AN
EYE ON YOU KNOW WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
WITHHOLD RECOMMENDATION ON THE
POPULATION RELATED BUDGET
ADJUSTMENTS UNTIL THE MAY
REVISION WHEN THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL SUBMIT REVISED POPULATION
PROJECTIONS AND ASSOCIATED
BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS. OKAY AT
THANK YOU I WAS WONDERING I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT-
LOOKING AT THE TABLE YOU HAVE
HERE YOU HAVE SOME FLUCTUATION.
THAT'S GOING TO BE HAPPY AND
HAPPENING WITH THE POPULATIONS
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS- AND SO
WHAT HAPPENS WITH STAFFING
LEVELS WHEN WE HAVE. THESE
FLUCTUATIONS. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
THIS IS BATTLING THE CLAIM
ACTIVITY DIRECTOR OFFICE OF THE
SCHOOL SERVICES FOR CDC ARE TO
THE EXTENT WE- I JUST HOUSING TO
ACCOMMODATE THE REDUCE
POPULATION THOSE ADJUSTMENTS ARE
CAPTURED WITHIN THE ANNUAL
POPULATION ADJUSTMENTS SO. IF
THERE IS A STAFFING REDUCTION
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT IT WILL BE
TAKEN DOWN AT THAT TIME. FOR
EXAMPLE ME CLOSE TO LOCATION WAS
THAT YOU SHOULD BE TOOK DOWN
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY SESSIONS
ONE TIME EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY
SEVEN POSITIONS ON THE LAKE. AND
SO ARE THOSE PEOPLE THAT WERE
PINK SLIPPED THEIR VACANCIES
THAT YOU ALREADY HAD OR. I WOULD
HAVE TO DIVERT OR LABOR FOLKS TO
GET YOU MORE INFORMATION ON THE
EXACT PROCESS BUT THE IDEA WAS
IS THAT- POSITIONS WERE- WELL
WE'RE ACCOMMODATED THROUGH
VOLUNTARY TRANSFER PROCESS. AND
OTHER MOVEMENTS AND SO THE WE
MINIMIZED THE LAYOFFS- AND I
BELIEVE WE HAD VERY FEW IF ANY
LAYOFFS. OKAY THANK OKAY SO THEN
I JUST UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY SO
WE'RE NOT REDUCING. STOP US FOR
THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE WHICH IS
MOVING THEM AROUND. VACANT
POSITIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO THAT THE POSITIONS WERE
REDUCED AND THEN INSTEAD OF
BACKFILLING BEHIND A VACANT
POSITION AT ANOTHER INSTITUTION
WE'VE MOVED THAT PERSON TO THAT
THAT MAKE IT POSITION SO WE
DIDN'T HIRE A NEW POSITION WE
RELOCATED EVERY ALLOCATED OUT
BUT STILL TOOK BE COMMENSURATE
REDUCTION IN STAFFING LEVELS
STORE- STAFFING LEVELS WERE
REDUCED BY THOSE EVENTS. I THANK
YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
SEARED IN A COMBINATION OF BOTH. AND THEN HAVE WE BEEN ABLE TO
ELIMINATE THE BACKLOG IN THE
JAILS. WE HAVE WE NOT MANY
PEOPLE IN JAIL AWAITING TRANSFER
TO CDCR. RIGHT NOW WE'RE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED- THAT ARE IT IN THE
COUNTIES BECAUSE WE DID HAVE TO
SUSPEND INTAKE AS A RESULT OF
THE OMICRON SEARCH- AND SO WE
HAVE RESUMED INTAKE AT BOTH
NORTH KERN AND WHAT'S GOING TO
LIMITED BASIS- AND WE ARE. YOU
KNOW AS SOON AS IT SAFE TO.
BRING THOSE- OFFENDERS INTO THE
STATE'S INSTITUTIONS WILL DO SO
BUT WE ARE SLOWLY BRINGING THEM
BACK SO THAT WE CAN OBSERVE ALL
PUBLIC PROTOCOLS AND
SPOKESPERSONS. DISTANCING AND
QUARANTINE. ARE WE STARTING TO
CREATE A PLAN AROUND THE IDEA
THAT THIS IS AND THAT MAKE IT
IT'LL STAY WITH US. THE
PENTATHLON OF IRIS. THANK YOU
WHAT WE HAVE- WHAT'S WHERE WE
HAVE MANY PROTOCOLS IN PLACE-
OUR ROADMAP TO RE OPENING AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE DONE TO.
ESTABLISH MOVEMENT WITHIN THE
INSTITUTIONS TESTING VACCINES-
AND QUARANTINES SO ALLOF THOSE
THINGS ARE WHAT ARE NOW PUT IN
PLACE AND ESTABLISHED WORKING
WITH OUR HEALTHCARE PARTNERS THE
RECEIVER'S OFFICE AND SO THOSE
WILL REMAIN IN EFFECT- TO THE
EXTENT WE HAVE THE SOCCER- TO
OCCUR. OCCURS OKAY THANK YOU
BECAUSE OF COLLEAGUES ANYONE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK
YOU THEN WE CAN MOVE ON TO
UPDATE ISSUE NUMBER TWO. WHICH
IS AN UPDATE ON COVER NINETEEN
IN THE PRESENCE. HELLO KATHLEEN
ALLISON SECRETARY FOR CITY
CIGAR- GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME AND OUR CDCR STAFF
TO BE HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED
SEVERAL SEVERAL PROPOSALS THAT
ALLOW US TO TAKE THE NECESSARY
STEPS TO RESPOND TO COMPETE
NINETEEN. ENHANCED THE STAFF
MISCONDUCT PROCESS. IMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
CONTINUED REHABILITATIVE AND
EDUCATIONAL INVESTMENTS AND
USHER THE DEPARTMENTS
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE INTO THE FUTURE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH YOU OVER
THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS ON THE
BUDGET AND OUR PROPOSALS. AS THE
- AS WELL AS TO REITERATE OUR
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUING
TRANSPARENCY AND INFORMATION
SHARING EFFORTS. BEFORE I HANDED
OVER TO THE DIRECTOR RIDDLE
INSTITUTIONS- THIS GIPSON AND TO
OUR DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DR BACK I'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE YOU SOME CURRENT
STATISTICS. CURRENTLY 70% OF OUR
STAFF AND 82% OF OUR POPULATION
. ARE FULLY VACCINATED AS
COMPARED TO THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
OF 64% FOSSILIZATION REMAIN LOW
WITH THE COMIC CON SURGE IN
LARGE PART DUE TO OUR
VACCINATION EFFORTS WITH THE
POPULATION AND AGGRESSIVE
IDENTIFICATION AND TREATMENT OF
THOSE WHO EXPERIENCE SYMPTOMS.
IN ADDITION THE DEPARTMENT TOOK
QUICK ACTION TO PROTECT THE
POPULATION BY CLOSING THE INTAKE
SUSPENDED IN PERSON VISITING A
FAMILY VISITING AND LIMITING
UNNECESSARY MOVEMENT THROUGHOUT
A STATE WIDE MODIFICATION
PROGRAM. I'M NOW GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO DR TO DIRECTOR GIPSON
AND DOCTOR BACK TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
MEASURES TAKEN TO ADDRESS CODE.
NINETEEN WITHIN OUR INSTITUTIONS
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM KIND OF GETS INTO
THE DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS AND THANK YOU
SECRETARY ALISON. IS I JUST WANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF THE
STEPS THE DEPARTMENT HAS
CONTINUED TO TAKE EVERY SINCE
THE PANDEMIC STARTED. TO HELP
MITIGATE THE SPREAD OF KOBE IT
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM TO KEEP OUR
POPULATION AND OUR STAFF SAFE.
WE CONTINUE TO FOLLOW PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE AS IT RELATES TO
SELL SCREENING OR COVERT NINETY
SYSTEM SYMPTOMS WHAT ARE
EMPLOYEES WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT BEFORE EMPLOYEES REPORT TO
WORK. THEY ARE CONDUCTING A SELF
SCREENING THAT THEY HAVE COBIT
NINETEEN SYMPTOMS THEY ARE NOT
REPORTING. WE CONTINUE TO TEST
BOTH OUR STAFF AND THE
POPULATION. WE CONDUCT
SURVEILLANCE TESTING WITH OUR
STAFF WHO ARE UNVACCINATED TO
TEST FLIGHTS A WEEK. AS WELL AS
WELL WE ARE IN THE OUTBREAK
PHASE AT A PRISON WE INCREASE
THE FREQUENCY OF TESTING FOR
BOTH. STAFF AND THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION. WE CONTINUE TO PRAY
AND UTILIZE I. ACQUIRED PROTOCOL
WHEN I. A POSITIVE CASE OF CODE
THAT ARE SYSTEM. OR THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS CLOSE
CONTACTS. WE CONTINUE TO
ENFORCEABLE ASKING MANDATE WITH
OUR POPULATION AND OUR STAFF.
OUR STAFF WHO ARE REQUIRED TO
WEAR QUE IN NINETY FIVE. OR IN
NINETY FIVE BASED ON THEIR WORK
SITE. AS WELL AS OUR POPULATION
WHO WERE PROVIDED SURGICAL
MASKS. ADVOCATE IN NINETY FIVE.
WE CAN TAILOR ENCOURAGE
VACCINATIONS ARE STAFF AND THE
POPULATION. AND I GET EXCITED
OVER THE MEMBERS OF THE
SECRETARY JUST SHARE BECAUSE YOU
LOOK BACK A FEW MONTHS AGO IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE IF
THE TECH OR WHAT ARE STAFF
MEMBERS. AND WE WERE AT SIXTY
FOUR PERCENT. AND TO SEE TODAY
THAT WERE AT 72% AND 8% INCREASE
SHOWS THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS
TO CONTAIN ENCOURAGE VACCINATION
AND BOASTING. AMONG OUR STAFF
AND THE INCARCERATED POPULATION
. WE CONTINUE TO DO OGLE THE
PATIENT EDUCATION AND EDUCATION
FOR STAFF AS IT RELATES TO COPE
AT NINETEEN. UNDERSTANDING THE
DEPARTMENT HASN'T BEEN SPARED
FROM HELP WITH THE TEETH THAT WE
SEE OUT IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
IT CONTINUES TO BE A DUE
DILIGENCE THAT OUR EFFORTS TO
CONTINUE TO GET FOLKS TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE. OF
COMPLIANT WITH A PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE AND COBIT PROTOCOLS. IN
RESPONSE TO THE- OPPRESSORS THE
DEPARTMENT ACTIVATED DEPARTMENTS
OPERATIONS CENTER AT A STATEWIDE
LEVEL. AND AT THE PRESENT THE
INCIDENT COMMAND POST STEP.
THESE TWO ENTITIES THE
DEPARTMENT'S OPERATIONS CENTER
FROM A STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE.
THE INSTITUTIONAL INCIDENT
COMMAND POST FROM THE
INSTITUTIONAL LEVELS. ALLOW THIS
INDUSTRY TO REALLY. MANAGE AND
NAVIGATE OUR WAY THROUGH THE
RESEARCH IDENTIFIER RESOURCE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS RESOURCE
NEED IS QUICKLY. IDENTIFY
STRATEGIES BEST PRACTICES ABOUT
COLLABORATIVE PERSPECTIVE
BETWEEN CDC ARE AT CCAC AT. A
DISPLAY AT THE SECRETARY SPOKE
ABOUT WE DID A MODIFIED PROGRAM
FOR FIVE WEEKS WHICH ENDED
YESTERDAY TO REALLY SLOW DOWN
MOVEMENT WITHIN THE SYSTEM. TO
BE ABLE TO MITIGATE THE SPREAD
OF COBIT. AT AND THAT INCLUDED-
SUSPENDING OF COUNTY INTAKE OR
REACH TO BE ONLY REDUCING THE
NUMBERS AS WELL AS ALL THE ALLOW
INNOCENT MOVEMENT WITHIN THE
SYSTEM. WE ALSO. CONGREGATE
ACTIVITIES VISITING PROGRAMMING
EDUCATION I ISSUE THE T. BUT
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPORTANCE FOR
OUR POPULATION TO STAY CONNECTED
WITH THEIR LOVED ONES ON THE IN
THE COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS FOR
THE LOVED ONES TO BE ABLE TO
REACH OUT AND CHECK ON THEIR
LOVED ONES IN SIGHT. WE MAKE
SURE THAT THE POPULATION HAD
ACCESS TO TELEPHONES. VIDEO
BETHANY AS WELL AS RECREATIONAL
YARD CANTEEN SERVICES A DELIVERY
OF EDUCATIONAL SELF HELP.
MATERIALS TO THEIR CELLS SO THAT
THEY CAN STAY BUSY. AS STATED
THE MODIFY PROGRAM IS TODAY SO
OUR PRISONS WILL BE REVERTING
BACK TO THE FACE THAT THEY FALL
INTO ON THEIR DEPARTMENTS REACH
ROADMAP TO RE OPENING. AND WE
CONTINUE TO UNDERSTAND THAT COLD
IT CHANGES IN OUR RESPONSE AS
THE CHANGES. WERE ANXIOUS TO GET
BACK TO NORMAL PROGRAM BUT IN
OUR SYSTEM. SO WE WORK ON A NEW
ROADMAP TO RE OPENING THAT IS
BEING RELEASED TODAY- THAT HELPS
TO REALLY GO GUYS TO OUR
PRESENCE ABOUT HOW WE NAVIGATE.
AND THE NUMBER OF DAYS IT MAY
TAKE BETWEEN A POSITIVE CASE
BEFORE THEY COULD MOVE TO THE
NEXT PHASE. SO IF YOU CHECK OUR
WEBSITE YOU'LL SEE PROBABLY OVER
THE NEXT. FEW DAYS MANY WILL
STILL BE IN AT OUTBREAK FAZER
PHASE ONE AS WE NAVIGATE OUR WAY
THROUGH. AND THAT HAVE A
POSITIVE. CASES WITHIN A CERTAIN
TIME PERIOD. AS WE LOOKED AT
LAW. AND GET BACK TO OPEN OUR
PRESS UP BELOW BIT IT MEANS
INCREASING. BUT THE SYSTEM-
INCREASE AND TAKE ON THE COUNTY
JAILS AS A SECRETARY SPOKE-
SPOKE EARLIER. WE DO HAVE A
COUNTY BACK LAW. AS A WE ARE
WORKING TO BRING THOSE FOLKS AND
FROM THE COUNTIES. BUT
UNDERSTANDING THAT ALL MOVEMENT
WITHIN THE SYSTEM. OF COURSE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S MOVEMENT
MATRIX REQUIRES. TESTING OF THE
INDIVIDUAL AT. THE BITE
QUARANTINE PERIOD. SO WE'RE
GOING EVERY WE CAN TO MAKE MORE
SAY IN THIS. TO MEDICAID SPREAD
OF HOPE IT. ADDITIONALLY WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT OUR
VENTILATION SYSTEMS WITH OUR
PRESENCE. AND WHERE APPROPRIATE
OUR STAFF OR- INSTALLING MARC.
WE HAVE ALSO PURCHASE. A
PORTABLE HELP A FILTER UNITS
THAT WE ARE INSTALLING
CONGREGATE AREAS. EDUCATION I.
S. U. T. T. VISIBLE SPACES SO
THAT WE CAN INCREASE CAPACITY
AND GET BACK TO NORMALIZE OUR
PROGRAM OUR POPULATION. AND
THOSE WE SERVE. AB AS SECRETARY
STEP BY STEP AND DOCTOR BAKER
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU. I DO
HAVE A ALEJO. HI GREETINGS MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME'S
ORLANDO SANCHEZ WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WITH ALL ACTION ON THE PROPOSED
RESOURCES FOR COVERT NINETEEN
RESPONSEAND TOLERATE VICE
PROPOSAL AT THE MAY REVISION IS
AVAILABLE. WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
CDCR WILL NEED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE FOR COVERT NINETEEN
RESPONSE. HOWEVER AT THE TIME
THAT WE CONDUCTED OUR ANALYSIS
THE DEPARTMENT WAS NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT INFORMATION
TO JUSTIFY THE ESTIMATED COSTS.
EXAMPLE THE DEPARTMENT HAS NOT
PROVIDED PROJECTIONS ON THE
NUMBER OF INMATES EMPLOYEES
REQUIRING TEST. THE COST PER
TEST OR THE AMOUNT OF EXPECTED
OVER TIME THAT LED TO THESE
COULD GET PROJECTIONS. IN
ADDITION THE PROTECT THE
PROJECTIONS OF THE INMATE
POPULATION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE IS LIKELY TO BE REVISED
DOWNWARD AT THE MAY REVISION. AS
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN THE
HEARING. IT IS ALSO POSSIBLE
THAT CHANGES IN THE PANDEMIC
CONDITIONS SUCH AS EMERGENCE OF
A NEW VARIANT COULD REQUIRE
CHANGES TO THE LEVEL OF
RESOURCES. AND CURRENTLY
PROPOSED. THEREFORE WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTING THE
DEPARTMENT OF PROVIDE A REVISED
PROPOSAL SHOULD INCLUDE ADEQUATE
JUSTIFICATION. AND ACCOUNT FOR
THE REVISED PROJECTIONS AND ANY
CHANGES AND PANDEMIC CONDITIONS
THANK AND I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. HI THANK YOU I HAVE
TWO QUESTIONS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
IT WILL FIRST OF ALL I WANNA OF
KNOWLEDGE THE IMPROVEMENT THAT
WE'VE SEEN AND VACCINATIONS FROM
THE LAST TIME. WE WERE HERE AND
SO I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
IF THE IF THE CITY STATEWIDE
SYSTEM- THAT A LOT OF PROGRESS-
BUT WE DO HAVE A COUPLE PRESENTS
WHERE ON THE PROGRESS IS NOT AS
IMPACTFUL AS YOU SEEN IN OTHER.
PLACES AND THEN FROM THE LIST
THE DA PROVIDE IT WE ALSO HAVE
THE CONTRACTORS WHO ARE FALLING
BEHIND IN THEIR VACCINATION
RATES COMPARED. TO YOUR STAFF SO
CAN YOU TALK TO US ABOUT THE
STRATEGIES THAT YOU'RE USING TO
TRY TO IMPROVE- THE RATES
AMONGST CONTRACTORS. AND THEN
ALSO WITH A SPECIFIC PROCESS
OVERSEEN A VERY DIFFERENT. A
NUMBER FOR EXAMPLE AT THE- HI
THIS THERE IS THE- DO WE HAVE
SOMETHING SPECIFIC TO TARGET
THOSE. WITHOUT LIARS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- KIND OF GIPSON
DIRECTOR I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS AND INVITE
DOCTOR BIG TO COME IN IF I
MISSED SOMETHING AS SO AS IT
RELATES TO THOSE PRESENT THAT
HAVE A LOW VACCINATION RATES TO
AND I WOULD DARE SAY THEIR
VACCINATION RATES ALIGNED WITH
THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY'RE AT.
AND SO WE CONTINUE TO. THE BUG
STRATEGIES TALK ABOUT. YOU KNOW.
WE UTILIZE OUR CENTERS FAR STAFF
THE POPULATION. BUT ALSO WE'VE
HAD SOME SUCCESS IN IN YOU KNOW
ON THE CRIME KIND OF- MAYBE SPOT
IS A LITTLE BIT BUT WE'VE HAD
SOME SUCCESS WITH DOING WHAT WE
CALL A VACCINATION BEAR. AT
PRESENT IS WHETHER IT'S FOR
STAFF WORKS FOR THE POPULATION.
THAT WE PASS THE SUCCESS THAT
WE'VE EMPLOYED AT OTHER
INSTITUTIONS. AND I'M SURE WE'RE
STILL LOOK INTO THE COMPUTER BOY
THAT AT VARIOUS OTHER PRESENTS.
THE GLEE. FOR PLEDGE OF WILL
PLEDGE ON FLAWS OF. EDUCATION
AT. A DAY TO SPEND WITH JUST
TALKING TO WALKING WITH THE
STAFF AND POPULATION IT REALLY
INCENTIVIZE THEM. AND GET PEOPLE
TO WANT TO VACCINATE THEM WHAT'S. ARE VACCINATED IS THE- WANT TO
GET THE- AND WELL. BUT I I'VE
BEEN DARE SAY YOU SEE THE LOW
BACK. RATES ARE VERY SO TO WHAT
YOU SEE IN THIS COMMUNITIES OF
THOSE PRESENTS ARE LOCATED. WE
CONTINUE TO WORK OUR CCAC AS A
CDCR AND CLEAN IT UP THE
CONTRACTOR NUMBERS AND ENSURING
THAT. THOSE CONTRACTORS WHO
PROVIDE SERVICES WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM. ARE COMPLIANT WITH OUR
VACCINATION REQUIREMENTS AND OR
TESTING REQUIREMENTS
UNDERSTANDING THAT. THEY AS
ROBERT YOU KNOW WE ARE STILL
WORKING THROUGH THAT PROCESS SO
I KNOW WE HAVE STAFF LOOKING
TOTALLY. ENGAGING WITH THE
VENDORS AND THE CONTRACTORS TO
MAKE SURE THEY UNDERSTAND THEIR
STAFF HAVE TO COMPLY- BUT WE
CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS TO TRY TO
GET THOSE NUMBERS HIGHER. THANK
YOU DIRECTOR GIPSON JOSEPH
SPECTOR RECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. I THINK THE ONLY
THINGS I WOULD ADD TO THAT ARE-
FOR ALL NEW CONTRACTORS THERE'S
AN EXPECTATION THAT THEY WILL
BE. VACCINATED WHEN THEY START
WITH US OR HAVE BEEN APPROVED
ACCOMMODATION. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE FOUND AS WE'VE GONE
THROUGH OUR LIST IS THAT. WE
HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS LISTED IN VARIOUS
INSTITUTIONS CONTRACTORS. WHO
MIGHT BE COMING IN QUARTERLY
SEMI ANNUALLY ANNUALLY THE
SERVICE AREA WHERE VARIOUS
EQUIPMENT FOR EXAMPLE. OR THEY
MAY HAVE AND- ARE SERVICING A
GREAT MENTOR PROVIDING SOME
SERVICE IN THE PAST AND REALLY.
HAVE NOT BEEN ANY INSTITUTION IN
QUITE SOME TIME. SO WE'VE
INVESTED A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
ENERGY IN ENSURING THAT THOSE
LISTS ARE CURRENT. AND I BELIEVE
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
OUR NUMBERS. ONE OTHER THING I
WOULD ADD TO WHAT DIRECTOR
GIPSON SAID IS THAT. YES FOR THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF OUR
CLASSIFICATIONS IN. POLITICAL
AND CUSTODY. OUR VACCINATION
RATES YOUR PASS. WHAT'S FOUND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND ALSO IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE TO OFFER. AND ENCOURAGE
AND EDUCATE PEOPLE WE DO KNOW
THAT THOSE WHO ARE VACCINATED.
ARE LESS LIKELY TO GET INFECTED
LESS LIKELY TO TRANSMIT TO
OTHERS AND- MOST IMPORTANTLY
LESS LIKELY TO. BE HOSPITALIZED
OR SUFFER SEVERE CONSEQUENCES
OF. BEING INFECTED SO WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO TARGET ALL
OF OUR. UNVACCINATED RESIDENTS
AND STAFF. THANK YOU WE COULD
JUST CONTINUE TO PROVIDE US WITH
UPDATES- LIKE I SAID I DO ONE OF
THE KNOWLEDGE OF PROGRESS THAT
HAS BEEN MADE VOTE. WE HAVE SOME
PROGRESS TO CONTINUE ON
ESPECIALLY AS WE WANT TO KEEP
BOTH STAFF AND MADE SAFE AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AS WELL WE
KNOW THAT AN OUTBREAK. THE
PRESENT OFTENTIMES THESE TOPICS
IN THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
AS WELL- COLLEAGUES QUESTION TH.
MISTER JONES SAWYER. CONNECTION
JUST KIND OF CURIOUS- OBVIOUS
I'M REALLY ENCOURAGED INTO. IN
SOME WAYS WHEN THE COMMAND CDCR.
ON GETTING THE VACCINATION RATES
UP SO HIGH- IN SOME WAYS IT'S
REALLY REMARKABLE FROM WHAT I
WAS HEARING EARLIER. AND AND
KEEPING IT YOU KNOW 15% EIGHTY
PERCENT. OF IT REALLY REALLY
GOOD. THE CONTRACTORS THAT ARE
COMING IN IS IT KIND OF. AND
THIS IS PROBABLY MORE GLOBAL
TRYING TO GET A SENSE. OF WHY.
THEY DON'T WANT WHAT ARE THEY
TELLING YOU WHY THEY'RE NOT
GETTING VACCINATED. AMADOR IS
THE THING WHICH YOU JUST SAID A
MATTER OF FREQUENCY THEY'RE IN
THERE SO INFREQUENT THAT THEY
MAY NOT BELIEVE THEY NEED TO BE
VACCINATED- IS THERE RATIONALE
IS IT IS IT INFORMATION THAT
THEY'RE GETTING THAT TELLS THEM
FROM THEIR COMMUNITY THAT THEY
NEED. OR THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
VACCINATED EVEN THOUGH OF THE
STATE EMPLOYEES LOOK LIKE
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
. TRYING TO COMPLY. DID ANYONE I
THINK IT'S A MIXTURE OF ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU HAVE SAID
ARE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC IS
FOR A LARGE ORGANIZATION LIKE
THIS TRYING TO HAVE A GOOD
LISTING OF EVERY SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S COMING IN AND
OUT OF ONE OF YOUR INSTITUTIONS
CAN BE VERY CHALLENGING IT'S
SUCH A LARGE- SERVICE THAT THAT
IS PROVIDED AND SO- I CAN'T SIT
HERE AND SAY THAT WHAT CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF THE CONTRACTORS
ARE NOT INTERESTED IN BEING
VACCINATED. OR NOT BUT I THINK
THAT BY THE TIME WE GET THROUGH
THIS PROCESS WE'LL FIND IT THEIR
ACCEPTANCE IN DECLINATION RATE
IS PROBABLY MORE LINKED TO THE
ACCOUNT TEAM WHICH THEY MAY HAVE
BEEN THEIR CLASSIFICATION AS
WE'RE SEEING WITH CALIFORNIANS
ALL OVER THE STATE. I GUESS I
WAS ASKING ANY SPECIFIC. THAT
THE BACKS IN VACCINATIONS DON'T
WORK THAT. YOU COULD CAUSE MORE
PROBLEMS AS A MULTIPLIER. OR I
JUST DON'T WANT TO DO IT AND YOU
CAN MAKE ME. A FRONTRUNNER GET
TO. WELL DIRECTOR GIPSON MAY
HAVE- IT DISHMAN FORMATION ON
THIS BUT I THINK WE'RE SEEING A
FULL RANGE OF. OPINIONS AMONG
BOTH THOSE WHO LIVE AND WORK IN
PRISON. ONE SECOND VERY
IMPRESSED BY IS HOW PEOPLE ARE
MAKING DECISIONS BASED UPON
THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL PERCEIVED
RISK FACTORS AND BY THAT I MEAN.
ARE AMONG OUR RESIDENTS FOR
EXAMPLE ME VERY INFORMED
DECISIONS IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ACCEPTANCE RATE AMONG THOSE WHO
ARE ELDERLY HAVE MULTIPLE
COMORBIDITIES. WHO ARE MOST AT
RISK FOR ADVERSE OUTCOMES
THEY'VE ACCEPTED THIS VACCINE AT
A RATE OF OVER NINETY PERCENT.
EXCEPT MISTER IS THAT OVER 80%
AND THIS IS A POPULATION THAT
HAS NEVER ACCEPTED A VACCINE IN
OUR SYSTEM THAT MORE THAN SIXTY
PERCENT. SO I'VE BEEN VERY
IMPRESSED AND I THINK OUR
EMPLOYEES ARE DOING SIMILAR RISK
CALCULATIONS BASED UPON THEIR
SELF PERCEPTION OF RISK. IN
WHERE THEY GET. THEIR NEWS AND
THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA. OKAY IN A
RESERVE ASK IS A BE TRANS. TO
THE STATE AS A WHOLE I MEAN IF
YOU'RE VERY SUCCESSFUL. AT A
POPULATION THAT MAY BE A LITTLE
RETICENT TO DO THIS IN YOUR
RATES ARE THIS HIGH. IT COULD BE
APPLICABLE TO REST THE
CALIFORNIA OF BEING ABLE TO DO
SO THAT'S- KIND OF WHAT I'M
ASKING I KNOW IT'S A MICROCOSM
OF THE STATE. BUT IT COULD BE A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF HOW WE CAN GET
MORE PEOPLE VACCINATED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER LUCKY.
YEAH MIKE MY QUESTION IS JUST TO
FOLLOW UP ON THE POINT THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP BY THE L. A. O. THAT
SAYS THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING THE ONGOING A COVERT
NINETEEN MANAGEMENT ARE STILL
UNKNOWN AND UNPREDICTABLE WHAT'S
THE ARGUMENT FOR THE
APPROPRIATION THAT STATED HERE
OVER GRANTING SPENDING AUTHORITY. GOOD AFTERNOON AT MADELINE
MCRAE MCC ARE SO WE BASE OUR JAN
TEN PROPOSAL ON THE LAST. YOU
MONTHS OF ACTUALS THAT WE HAD-
AND COMPARE THAT TO WHAT WE HAD
EXPENDITURES. AND SO WHAT WE
WILL BE DOING IS TAKING A LOOK
AT WHAT WE HAD AND WHAT WE'RE
WHERE WE'RE GOING AND LIKELY
UPDATED THAT THE REVISION WILL
RE ASSESS AT A REVISION SO. WE
INDICATED IN OUR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL THAT WHAT THE ESTIMATE
IS A POINT IN TIME. AND WILL BE
REFINED. OKAY THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE. OKAY WHEN ALSO WELCOME
ARCHER OR BUDGET MR KING. THANK
MEASURES JUST A QUICK QUESTION
BACK TO SEE IF YOURSELF I GUESS
DID DID I HEAR YOU CORRECTLY
THAT YOU. ARE ASKING THE NEW
CONTRACTORS TO GET VACCINATED
BUT DOES NOT IMPLY THAT THE-
CURRENT CONTRACTORS DON'T HAVE
TO. SWANA CLARIFIED THE WAS A
SERVER HEARD THAT CORRECTLY.
THANK YOU FOR ASKING FOR THE
CLARIFICATION NO EVERYONE IS
REQUIRED TO BE VACCINATED HER
PROVIDE A APPROVED ACCOMMODATION
AS TO WHY THEY'RE NOT IT'S JUST
THAT WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYONE WHO COMES TO STATES
SERVICE NOW. KNOWS THAT UP FRONT
AND THAT'S TAKEN CARE OF BY
PRIOR TO THEM STARTING. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
AND IT JUST SOUNDS LIKE IT'S-
ARE YOU HAVING TROUBLE.
IMPLEMENTING THAT WITH YOUR
CONTRACTORS. I WOULDN'T SAY IT'S
THE CONTRACTORS PER SE IT'S JUST
A LARGE VOLUME FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE TRYING TO TRACK
EVERYBODY DOWN. THEY'RE WORKING-
YOUR DIFFERENT SHIPS DIFFERENT
DAYS SOME IN THE INSTITUTION A
DAY A MONTH TWO DAYS A MONTH
ONCE A QUARTER. IT CAN BE
CHALLENGING DURING THAT SO- I
DON'T THINK IT'S A PARTICULAR
PROBLEM TO THE CONTRACTORS. DO
YOU THINK YOU YOU MADE A REALLY
GOOD POINT THAT- HAS LA
SOMETIMES PEOPLE'S OPINIONS HAVE
LESS TO DO WITH THEIR-
CLASSIFICATION OR WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AT A PARTICULAR PLACE
VERSES WHERE THEY'RE WHERE
THEY'RE LIVING IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. SO BASED ON THAT
COMMENT- THE PEOPLE WHO I
IMAGINE ARE IN CHARGE OF
ENFORCING. THESE RULES OF THE
WARRANTS AND THE WARRANTS ARE
LIVING IN THESE COMMUNITIES AS
WELL. ARE. YOU GETTING FULL
COOPERATION FROM YOUR WORDS. IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT FRANTICALLY
PLEASED WITH. HOW MUCH SENIOR
CUSTOMER EITHER SHIP AS IN
BRACED. VACCINATIONS WHEN WE
LOOK AT CLASSIFICATIONS
INCLUDING WARDENS CHIEF.
ORDERLY'S CAPTAINS IN THE
TENANTS WERE SAYING ARE VERY
HIGH UPTAKE OF VACCINATIONS I
FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THE SENIOR
LEADERSHIP. ONE CALL DIDN'T AT
ALL OF THE INSTITUTIONS ARE VERY
SUPPORT. BUT WHY THE- FOR RATES
AT HIGH DESERT PELICAN BAY CCI.
I MEAN WE CAN GO ONBECAUSE
THERE'S THEY'RE ALL LISTED IN
THE RIGHT UP MILLCREEK. AGAIN I
THINK IT'S MORE RELATED TO- THE
BELIEFS AROUND VACCINATIONS AND
GOVERNMENTS IN GENERAL- ACROSS
OUR STATE YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
VERY. VERY HARD TO UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
BUT YOU ARE ALSO SAID THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT. SO YOU JUST ARE
ALLOWING PEOPLE NOT TO. FOLLOW
THE REQUIREMENT. WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NO ABSOLUTELY NOT
EVERYONE IS REQUIRED TO EITHER
BE VACCINATED FOR TO HAVE AN
APPROVED MEDICAL OR RELIGIOUS
ACCOMMODATION PERIOD. SELECTABLE
I THEIR SERVICE IN ORDER. I'M
SORRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM HALF
MY QUESTION THE BIGGEST YOU CAN
ANSWER AND THE ANSWER DIRECTOR
SO LET'S WITH THE HIGH DESERT
YOU GOT 30% 35% BECAUSE THE
STAFF. THE AND I GOT MY ARE YOU
ARE YOU TELLING ME THAT 64%
ACROSS THE STAFF HAVE A- THE
EXEMPTION OR- WHICH WHICH WOULD
BE WHICH WOULD SEEM FAIRLY.
FAIRLY HIGH. IT ALSO THAT 67%
WHICH IS EVEN HIGHER OF
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF HAVE A
SIMILAR EXEMPTION. SO HI THIS IS
KIRTI GIFT ND IF I COULD JUST
CLARIFY A BIT- CURRENTLY THE
ONLY FOLKS WHO ARE MANDATEDTO
BE VACCINATED. ARE THOSE WHO
FALL UNDER THE CDPH ORDER THAT
DIRECTED US THAT IF YOU HAVE
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES OR WE
WERE GOING TO HEALTH CARE
LOCATION OTHER PROJECT. SO WE
HAVE STAFF WHO THE PRISONS ARE
C. A. C. F. C. M. S. CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
I APOLOGIZE. CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
FACILITY AND THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY AS EASY TO HELP CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY. AS
WELL AS FOR ALL OF OUR OTHER
PRISONS IS THOSE HEALTHCARE
MEDICAL- ANCILLARY STAFF WHO MAY
WORK IN OUR CORRECTIONAL
TREATMENT THIS- CENTERS ARE UP.
PATIENTS PSYCHIATRIC INPATIENT
BEDS ARE HEALTHCARE CLINICS WHO
ARE REQUIRED IN THE CDPH ORDERED
TO BE VACCINATED BY THE REST OF
OUR STAFF THERE IS NO
VACCINATION REQUIRED WE DO
ENCOURAGE VACCINATIONS AND IF
THEY ARE VACCINATED THEN THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO TWICE WEEKLY
TESTING I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
I'M GLAD YOU MENTIONED CMS
BECAUSE IT SAYS 52% OF
CONTRACTORS ARE NOT VACCINATED.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT OUR
DEBATE WAS TALKING ABOUT IS
WORKING THROUGH ON MANY OF THESE
CONTRACTORS PROVIDE SOME TYPE OF
. I THINK THERE ARE SERVICES TO
SERVICE- EQUIPMENT AT THE
PRESENT AS ALWAYS TRYING TO
TRACK DOWN THESE FOLKS BECAUSE-
BECOME MISSILES WILL RADICALLY
SOME OF THEM I THINK THAT'S WHAT
DOCTOR BECAUSE TALK ABOUT THE
AGENCIES ALLEGEDLY. BUT IF YOU
EVER PARTNERING IN A YEAR WITH A
CONTRACTOR I'M NOW WE HAVE A
SIPLE POLICY. YOU CAN EITHER
GIVE US THE INFORMATION AND YOU
DON'T. HAVE TO COME BACK IT'S
PRETTY SIMPLE ISN'T. YES YES
WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE THE WIDEST
FOR THE VERY LOW PERCENTAGE RATE
THIS IS ONLY TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE CONTRACTORS. TRY TO
TRACK DOWN TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE INDIVIDUALS. WHAT I SUSPECT
IS HAPPENING IN THIS IS THE PART
WHERE DR BIG TALK ABOUT WE'RE
TRYING TO CLEAN UP OUR DATA IN
SO FAR AS SOMEBODY'S CONTRACTORS
MAY ONLY CAME IN ONE TIME AND-THAT ONE TIME AND THEY'RE IN A
GOOD OUR SYSTEM AND IT MAY BEEN
A YEAR AGO. BECAUSE A VENDOR WHO
PROVIDES AT THE CHECKLIST
SERVICE MAY HAVE DIFFERENT
PEOPLE WHO IN. TIME AS ALWAYS AS
MAKE IT SURE AS WE GO THROUGH
THE SYSTEM THAT WE PUT PEOPLE
OUT THERE NOT. NO LONGER.
BURBANK SERVICE YEAH BECAUSE FOR
EXAMPLE FOR THEM WHEN THEY
CONTRA. COMES IN AND YOU DON'T
HAVE THEM ON THE RECORD AND
THEY'RE NOT BACKS AND WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS. THAT'S ENOUGH. I WOULD
HAVE THE DEPARTED I BIG I WOULD
SUSPECT THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED IN
BUT I WOULD. HERE HE COULD HE
COULD RESPOND YOU HAVE RESPOND
FOR. THANKS AND FIRST I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING I WAS I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT THOSE EMPLOYEES. WERE
MANDATED TO BE VACCINATED I
APPRECIATE THE CLARIFICATION I'M
TOTALLY MISUNDERSTOOD YOUR
QUESTION. NO IT THAT'S THE EASY
PART EASY PART IS SAYING THAT IF
YOU'RE NOT VACCINATED OR HAVE AN
EXEMPTION YOU CAN'T COMMAND.
THAT THE CHALLENGER WE'VE HAD
AND WE'VE MADE HUGE PROGRESS
OVER THE LAST SIX WEEKS OR SO IS
IDENTIFYING ALL THOSE CONTACTING
THOSE PEOPLE I DON'T WANT TO
LEAVE ANYONE WITH THE OPPRESSION
THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE JUST
COMING. IN AND OUT **** NILLY
DURING THIS PERIOD OF TIME
THAT'S I'M CONFIDENT SAYING
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING. RIGHT BUT
BUT BUT BUT YOU'VE GOT TO MY CAR
SO YOU'LL CMF. YOU GOT TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE CONTRACTORS
THAT AREN'T VACCINATED. WHAT
HAPPENS IF ONE OF THEM SHOWS UP
TO DO THEIR JOB. SO WE HAVE A
LISTED EVERY INSTITUTION OF
EVERYONE WHO REQUIRED TO BE
VACCINATED AND IF PEOPLE COME IN
AND THEY'RE NOT BACKS NEEDED.
ARM THEY AND THEIR SUPERVISOR OR
THE PERSONAL TO CONTRACT FOLLOWS
UP WITH THOSE FOLKS. STORY CAN.
GO AHEAD SO THEY'LL HAVE TO SHOW
PROOF OF VACCINATION BEFORE
BEING ABLE TO ENTER THE FACILITY
. ARE WE DON'T HAVE A
VACCINATION CARD THAT THEY'RE
REQUIRED DO CHAU. BUT ALL THOSE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AND
I'M CONFIDENT THAT THEY'RE NOT
COMING IN AND OUT WITHOUT BEING
VACCINATED THIS TIME. OKAY SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE UNDERSTANDING IS
IN THAT FACILITY FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE DIRECTOR LET'S NOT
FACILITIES THAT ARE A
REQUIREMENT TO VACCINATE THAT
ANYBODY ENTERING THE FACILITY-
WOULD EITHER HAVE TO BE
VACCINATED OR OR THE- SHOW FOR
YOU KNOW- OR HAVE A EXEMPTION.
THAT'S CORRECT AND I WOULD BE
GLAD TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU- IN
THE NEXT WEEK OR ARE CONTINUALLY
WITH THAT LIST OF CONTRACTORS
BECAUSE AS I SAID AS WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THAT REFINING A LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO AREN'T EVEN
REALLY STILL WORKING FOR US AT
ALL. THANK YOU. IRAQ MISSPELLED
IF. I AM JUST CURIOUS AND I'M I
DID STEP IN- A LITTLE- AFTER
YOUR YOUR UPDATE WHAT'S THE KEYS
OF ABLE BEING ABLE TO GET A
VACCINE DO YOU DO THEM ON SITE
DO. WHAT STAFF NEED TO GO TO
ANOTHER LOCATION FOR A VACCINE.
NO THANKS FOR ASKING WE MAKE
AVAILABLE VACCINES AT ALL OF THE
INSTITUTIONS WHERE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ON ALL SHIPS SO IT'S VERY
EASY AND WE CONTINUE TO
ADVERTISE SO THAT AVAILABILITY
TO OUR EMPLOYEES. AND IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBERS THE VOTE SO WE
HAVE. DATA AND CALCULATIONS WERE
VACCINATED PARTIALLY VACCINATED-
DO WE HAVE ALSO LOOSE BOOSTED
AND UNVACCINATED AND OF THE
UNBOXED POPULATION WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF HAD. CODED AND
WHAT PERCENTAGE OVERALL HAVE HAD
COVERAGE. WE CAN MAKE THAT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO YOU IT
THESE ARE VARIOUS THINGS THAT WE
MONITOR AS WELL SO IF YOU'D LIKE
TO PROVIDE US A LIST OF
SPECIFICS I ENSURE WE CAN
GENERATE THAT. THANK YOU. THE
WALK. ANYMORE QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME PLEASE
KEEP US UPDATED AS THOSE NUMBERS
HOPEFULLY IMPROVE. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE-
CC ARE IN THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. ON STAFF
COMPLAIN PROCESS BUDGET PROPOSAL
WITH A TOPIC WE- HAD A LOT OF
QUESTIONS FOR LAST YEAR AND I
HOPE WE GET SOME BETTER ANSWERS
THIS YEAR. THE PANEL GETTING
STARTED AS LISTED ON THE AGENDA
. THANK YOU SORRY GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AMY MILLER
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF CORRECTIONAL POLICY
RESEARCH AND INTERNAL OVERSIGHT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
IT IS THE ARTS REQUESTING
FUNDING AND POSITIONS TO
RESTRUCTURE THE DEPARTMENT STAFF
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS SCREENING
REFERRAL INVESTIGATIVE AND
DISCIPLINARY PROCESSES. THE
FUNDING PROVIDED IN THIS REQUEST
WILL ENABLE THE DEPARTMENTTO
COMPLETELY RESTRUCTURE THE
PROCESS FOR REVIEWING ALEX
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
INVOLVING AN INCARCERATED PERSON
ARE PROBABLY. PREVIOUSLY
AGREEMENTS WAS REVIEWED AT THE
INSTITUTION FOR ALL OFFICE FOR
OTHER LOCATIONS WHERE THE
COMPLAINT ORIGINATED. IF IT WAS
DETERMINED TO INVOLVE A
COMPLAINT AGAINST STAFF IT WAS
SENT TO THE LOCAL HIRING
AUTHORITY GENERALLY THE HIGHEST
RANKING PERSON WITHIN THE STAFF
MEMBERS PROGRAMMER DIVISION. NOW
THE REVIEW OF ALLEGATIONS MADE
BY INCARCERATED PEOPLE AND
PAROLEES FROM THE INSTITUTION
CENTRAL OFFICES. WILL BE
TRANSFERRED FROM WHERE THEY
ORIGINATED TO A CENTRALIZED
SCREENING TEAM BUT THEN THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS AT
CDC OUR HEADQUARTERS. THE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM
REPLACES THE SCREENING OF
GRIEVANCES BY INSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITIES AND CENTRALIZES THAT
SCREENING IN ONE OFFICE FOR
ACCURACY AND CONSISTENCY. AS
WELL AS REMOVE ANY ACTUAL OR
PERCEIVED LOCAL FIRE BUT
ELIMINATING THE ABILITY OF
INSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITIES TO
REMOVE GRIEVANCES FROM THE
REVIEW PROCESS. ALL INSTITUTIONS
CENTRAL OFFICES WILL ROUTE
GRIEVANCES AND COMPLAINTS TO THE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM
WITHIN THREE BUSINESS DAYS OF
RECEIVING THE GRIEVANCE OR
COMPLAINT. THE CENTRALIZED
SCREENING TEAM IS TASKED WITH
REVIEWING THE COMPLAINT AND
DETERMINING WHETHER IT INCLUDES.
AN ALLOCATION OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT AND IF SO WHETHER
THAT SHOULD BE REVIEWED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THROUGH AN
ALLEGATION INQUIRY REFERRED OUR
Y. A FOR A CRIMINAL OR
ADMINISTRATIVE INVESTIGATION. TO
ASSESS THE CENTRALIZED GRADING
TEAM WITH THEIR DECISION MAKING
THE NEW PROCESS ALSO INCLUDES A
NEWLY CREATED ALLOCATION
DECISION INDEX THAT WILL BE USED
TO DETERMINE WHEN A COMPLAINT
WILL BE ROUTED. TO A WHITE APRON
DESTINATION. WELL EACH COMPLAINT
WILL BE INVESTIGATED THE
ALLEGATION DECISION INDEX
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIES THE
TYPES OF ALLEGATIONS THAT WILL
ALWAYS BE REFERRED TO THE OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR
INVESTIGATION. INCLUDING ALL
ALLEGATIONS OF MISCONDUCT
INVOLVING STAFF USE OF FORCE.
AND ALL ALLEGATIONS INVOLVING
STAFF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT TOWARDS
AN INCARCERATED PERSON- PROLATE
. THE INDEX ALSO INCLUDES
ALLEGATIONS INVOLVING DISHONESTY
DISCRIMINATION HARASSMENT
RETALIATION CODE OF SILENCE AND
INTEGRITY MATTERS SUCH AS
FAILING TO STOP MISCONDUCT BY
ANOTHER EMPLOYEE. WHEN AN
ALLEGATION IS NOT INCLUDED ON
THE ALLOCATION DECISIONS AND
ACTS IT WILL GENERALLY BE
REFERRED TO THE LOCAL HIRING
AUTHORITY FOR AN ALLEGATION
INQUIRY HOWEVER THE CENTRALIZED
SCREENING TEAM CAN STILL
REFERRED THE ALLEGATION TO
INTERNAL AFFAIRS. IF THEY
DETERMINE THAT BASED ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES DESCRIBED IN THE
COMPLAINT AND INVESTIGATION BY-
I A IS MORE APPROPRIATE. STAFF
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS THAT ARE
ROUTED TO INTERNAL AFFAIRS WILL
RECEIVE A FULL INVESTIGATION AND
WILL NOT BE FORWARDED TO THE
HIRING AUTHORITY UNTIL MANAGER
HAS DETERMINED THE INVESTIGATIVE
REPORT IS THOROUGH. COMPLETE AND
UNBIASED. LIKEWISE STAFF
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS THAT ARE
ROUTED TO THE INSTITUTION OR
PAROLE REGION FOR AN ALLEGATION
ENCOURAGE INQUIRY. WILL ALSO
HAVE TO BE REVIEWED AND APPROVED
BY AN INTERNAL AFFAIRS MANAGER
BEFORE THEY ARE FORWARDED TO THE
HIRING AUTHORITY ENSURING THE
WORK BY THE LOCALLY DESIGNATED
INVESTIGATOR IS ALSO THOROUGH.
COMPLETE AND UNBIASED. THESE
EFFORTS COUPLED WITH OTHER
INVESTMENTS AND CHANGES
REPRESENT SIGNIFICANT STEPS IN
OUR EFFORTS TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
. ALONG WITH ME- CHRIS THE BENCH
BYLER FROM THE OFFICE OF LEGAL
AFFAIRS AND KIMBERLY SEIPEL FROM
THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS WE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S OFFICE HERE
. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM EMERY
THING THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO GIVE YOU
SOME BACKGROUND INFORMATION ON
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S PROCESS
FOR MONITORING- STAFF COMPLAINTS
I'M IN TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT BEGAN DEVELOPING A
PROCESS TO ADJUST ADDRESS
INCARCERATED PERSONS COMPLAINTS
OF STAFF MISCONDUCT. THE O. I.
G. GAINES ADDED RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROVIDE CONTEMPORANEA
OVERSIGHT OF THAT PROCESS. THE
DEPARTMENT DEVELOPED A PROCESS-
WHICH WAS THE CREATION OF THE
ALLEGATIONS INQUIRY MANAGEMENT
SECTION ALSO CALLED AIMS- A UNIT
THAT WAS DEDICATED TO CONDUCTING
ENQUIRIES INTO ALLEGATIONS OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT. IN RESPONSE
THE- I. T. CREATED A TEAM OF
FIVE STAFF MEMBERS RESPONSIBLE
FOR MONITORING THE IN KIRBY'S
CONDUCTED BY GAINES. SINCE
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY UNTIL
NOW OUR TEAM OF FIVE CONTINUES
TO PROVIDE CONTEMPORANEOUSLY
OVERSIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENTS
PROCESS FOR REVIEWING AND
INVESTIGATING INCARCERATED
PERSONS ALLEGATIONS OF
MISCONDUCT. WE USE A COMBINATION
OF IN PERSON AND REMOTE
MONITORING TOOK OVER CD GAMES
AND CURRIES. AND WE ALSO
COLLECT- DATA AND ANALYZE
VARIOUS STAFF COMPLAINT DATA
POINTS INCLUDING WORKLOAD
STATISTICS AND THOSE COMPLAINTS
REFERRED TO AIMS BY THE PRESENTS
. GOING FORWARD AT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS IMPLEMENTED NEW
REGULATIONS IT IS OUR PROPOSAL
TO MONITOR THE DEPARTMENT'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR NEW
REGULATIONS ON THEIR NEW STAFF
COMPLAINT INVESTIGATION PROCESS
. WE ARE ASKING FOR STAFF TO
MONITOR APPROXIMATELY 30% OF THE
DECISIONS THAT WILL BE MADE BY
THEIR NEW A CENTER LIKE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM. TO
INSURE THE FACT TEAM IS MAKING
CONSISTENT DECISIONS IN THEIR
REFERRALS TWO CASES THAT WILL GO
TO THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS FOR TO THE LOCALLY
DESIGNATED INVESTIGATORS WE ARE
ALSO ASKING FOR STAFF TO MONITOR
10% OF THE INVESTIGATIONS THAT
WILL BE CONDUCTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT'S NEWLY CREATED.
ALLEGATIONS INVESTIGATION UNIT
AND WE INTEND TO MONITOR THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS TO ENSURE
THOROUGH COMPLETE AND UNBIASED
INVESTIGATIONS WE WILL ASSESS
THE DEPARTMENT'S IMPLEMENTATION
PROCESS AND THEN WE WILL ALSO
WORK ON A MECHANISM TO PROVIDE
THE DEPARTMENT WITH TIMELY
FEEDBACK AND TO ISSUE PUBLIC
REPORTS- THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
AND WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. L.
A. L.'S OFFICE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND WE FIND THAT THE
PROPOSAL- THE CDC ARE PROPOSAL
TO IMPLEMENT A NEW STAFF
COMPLAINT PROCESS IN LINE WITH
THE NEW REGULATIONS APPEARS
REASONABLE I'M HOWEVER WE FIND
THAT THE PROPOSED LEVEL OF
MONITORING OF THAT NEW PROCESS
BY THE O. I. G. MAY NOT BE
LEGISLATIVE EXPECTATIONS FOR
OVERSIGHT- SO WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DETERMINE ITS
SPECIFIC EXPECTATIONS FOR
OVERSIGHT OF THIS NEW STAFF
COMPLAINT PROCESS AND THEN
ONLINE B. O. I. G. RESOURCES
ACCORDINGLY. AND TO ASSIST THE
LEGISLATURE IN THINKING ABOUT
ITS EXPECTATIONS FOR OVERSIGHT
WE PROVIDE- THREE KEY QUESTIONS
FOR CONSIDERATION WHICH ARE ONE
SHOULD THE O. I. G. MONITOR THE
SCREENING OF ALL TYPES OF
COMPLAINTS RECEIVED BY TE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM OR
JUST- REGULAR GRIEVANCES AS IS
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
TWO SHOULD BE- I JIM A LARGER
PORTION OF INVESTIGATIONS-
BENNETT'S PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY
THAT PROPOSAL PER- WOULD UNDER
THE PROPOSAL OR YOU WOULD
MONITOR 10% OF INVESTIGATIONS-
IN COMPARISON UNDER EXISTING
PROCESS FOR HANDLING.
ALLEGATIONS THAT ARE REFERRED BY
WARDENS ANOTHER HIRING
AUTHORITIES ALLEGING MONITORS
ABOUT 15% OF INVESTIGATIONS AND
THEN THIRD IT SHOULD- I. G.
MONITOR THE QUALITY OF LOCAL
ENQUIRY REPORTS- AND UNDER THE
PROPOSAL- UNDER THE TWO
PROPOSALS. AT CDCR STAFF WOULD
MONITOR 100% OF THE QUALITY OF
THOSE- LOCAL AND GREATER UP
ROUGHLY THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
ANNUAL- REPORTS CONDUCTED BY
PRISON AND PAROLE STAFF- AND
AVOID YOU WOULD NOT MONITOR ANY
OF THEM- AND THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER WHETHER IT
WOULD LIKE- I. G. TO MONITOR. A
PORTION OF THAT IS- THOSE
REPORTS ARE IN PART THEMSELVES.
AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU. AT THANK YOU SO-
MAYBE THAT I'M TERRIFIED ME. HI
THIS IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE JUST WANTED TO
REGISTER A COUPLE OF COMMENTS IF
THAT'S OKAY. YES FRANKLY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
DEMONSTRATION WAS IN THE PROCESS
OF EXPLORING VARIOUS OPTIONS. IT
MAY BRING FORWARD A PROPOSAL FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN THE
SPRING THIS INCLUDES CONCERNED
RESOURCES AS IT RELATES TO
OVERSIGHT OF LOCAL INCREASE THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL PROVIDES
RESOURCES FOR THE O. I. G. TO
MONITOR APPROXIMATELY 10% OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS CONDUCTED BY THE
ALLEGATION INVESTIGATION UNIT OR
ROUGHLY A HUNDRED FORTY OUT OF
EIGHTY FOUR HUNDRED
INVESTIGATIONS. THIS PROPOSAL
WAS AIMED AT PROVIDING THOUGH I
G. WITH RESOURCES TO OVERSEE THE
MOST SERIOUS AND COMPLEX CASES
BASED ON THE ALLEGATION DECISION
INDEX THOSE INCORPORATED INTO
CITY SEWERS REGULATIONS. AS THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL CAN SPEAK TO
THE 10% IS A MEANINGFUL SAMPLE
SIZE THAT ALSO ACCOUNTS FOR A
BROAD RANGE OF ALLEGATIONS- THE
ALLEGATION INVESTIGATION UNIT
WILL BE INVESTIGATING WHILE
PROVIDING THE O. I. G. WITH THE
ABILITY TO OVERSEE THE MOST
SERIOUS CASES THIS LEVEL OF
MONITORING ALSO RECOGNIZES THE
MANY IMPROVEMENTS SEE THIS YEAR
HAS MADE TO ITS STAFF MISCONDUCT
PROCESS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS PROPOSAL
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS. AS WE
WORK THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
. OKAY I'M GONNA COME ACK TO
THE 10% SAID IN A LITTLE BIT
BUT- CAN WE GO BACK TO- THE 280%
OF THE COMPLAINTS THAT ARE GOING
TO GO BACK TO THE PRESENT-
THEY'RE STILL MISCONDUCT WITHIN
THOSE 80% THAT NEED TO BE.
INVESTIGATED AND IF
SUBSTANTIATED THERE NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS THE PROCESS
GOING TO BE ANY DIFFERENT FOR
THAT 80% AND EXILED QATARI DOING
THAT DIFFERENTLY THAN BEFORE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
MADAM CHAIR AND SO I AS
MENTIONED IT IN MY INTRODUCTION
WE ABSOLUTELY ARE GOING TO TREAT
THOSE DIFFERENTLY THAN WE USED
TO SO AT THE DEPARTMENT WE MADE
THE DECISION TO REALLY BROADEN
THE DEFINITION OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT AND IN THAT WE'VE
REALLY COVERED EVERYTHING FROM
FROM THE LEAST AREAS TO THE MOST
SERIOUS IN THAT THE DEFINITION.
BUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT BECAUSE
THERE WAS A VAST AMOUNT OF
CONCERN WITH THE WORK THAT WAS
BEING DONE LOCALLY WE'VE ELECTED
TO CHANGE OUR PROCESS SO THAT
EVEN THOUGH THAT WAS LESS
SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS ARE GOING
BACK TO THE INSTITUTIONS. THEY
WILL HAVE TO BE REVIEWED BY A
MANAGER IN THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND IT THIS
WILL BE THE SAME MANAGERS BY THE
WAY THAT ARE ALSO REVIEWING THE
WORK BEING DONE BY THE
ALLEGATION INVESTIGATION UNIT.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
LOOK AT THOSE REPORTS AND
DETERMINE IF THEY ARE THOROUGH
COMPLETE AND UNBIASED NO
DIFFERENT THAN THE SAME PER VIEW
THAT THEY'RE DOING FOR THE
INVESTIGATIONS BEING DONE BY
THEIR TEAM WE REALLY FEEL THAT
THIS WILL MITIGATE THE CONCERNS
OF- WORK QUALITY FROM THE
INSTITUTION LEVEL AND GIVE US A
BETTER OUTCOME OVERALL. AND THEN
AM I AM I CORRECT AGAIN TO THE
CITY OUR- AM I CORRECT THAT IT'S
THE WARDENS RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAKE THE FINAL DETERMINATION
THAT STAFF MISCONDUCT OCCUR OR
DID OCCUR. THAT IS CORRECT AND
SO WHAT KIND OF OVERSIGHT THAT
WE HAVE OVER THESE WARDENS AND
HOW BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T SOUND
VERY DIFFERENT THAN. THE
PREVIOUS SYSTEM THAT WAS FAILING
MATH. SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION IN OUR NEW PROCESS WE
HAVE NOW ADDED IN OVERSIGHT BY
OUR OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS IN
OUR ALLEGATION INVESTIGATION
UNIT WHICH MEANS MORE. OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS WERE PREVIOUSLY THEY
WERE GOING TO BE AIMS UNIT FOR
AN INQUIRY THERE WAS NO
OVERSIGHT BY OUR LEGAL TEAM. NOW
WE WILL HAVE INCORPORATED IN THE
OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS INTO
THAT PROCESS. AND SO THEY AS
THEY MONITOR THESE TYPES OF
ALLEGATIONS FOR THOSE THAT THAT
THEY'RE INVOLVED IN. THEY OF
COURSE FOLLOW THAT CASE ALL THE
WAY TO THE TO THE INSTITUTION-
TO THE HIRING AUTHORITY
DECISIONS AND THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY DURING THAT PROCESS IF
THEY DISAGREE WITH THE HIRING
AUTHORITY. TO ELEVATE THAT TO
THE NEXT LEVEL AT FOR ADDITIONAL
REVIEW AND SO WE'VE WE'VE
INCORPORATED THEM INTO THAT
PROCESS- FOR ADDITIONAL
OVERSIGHT AS TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT THE INSTITUTIONS.
THEY'RE INCORPORATED INTO THE
PROCESS FOR THAT 20% AND THE 80%
OR JUST FOR THE 20% THAT IT
YOU'RE CORRECT IN THATFOR THE
OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS WE'VE
INCORPORATED THEM INTO THE- OUR
CLAIMS THE STAFF MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS THAT ARE GOING TO GO
TO A LIGHT A FOR INVESTIGATION
THEY ARE NOT. ATTACHED TO THE
INSTITUTIONS ALLEGATION INQUIRY
PROCESS IN LAST WHEN IT IS
REVIEWED BY THE- OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS MANAGER THAT
MANAGER MAKES THE DECISION THAT
THAT PARTICULAR INQUIRY NEEDS
ADDITIONAL WORK AT BY AN
INVESTIGATOR AND THEREFORE WOULD
ENTERED INTO THE INVESTIGATION
PROCESS AT WHICH POINT. AT OUR
LEGAL TEAM AND ATTACH THAT. SO.
IT SOUNDS LIKE WE MADE SOME
PROGRESS MAYBE IN THE FRONT END
OF THINGS BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT
WE'VE MADE PROGRESS ON THE BACK
END OF THINGS I'M NOT SURE HOW
THAT'S GOING TO RESULT IN ANY
REAL CHANGES TO THE QUARTER INTO
THE ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE ARE.
TRYING TO CREATE HERE. IN ORDER
AND SO I KNOW WHAT YOU JUST
ANSWERED ME BUT IF I TRANSLATE
WHAT I HEARD IS THAT'S WHAT I
HEARD THE DO YOU. I'M JUST RAY
THAT WE'RE GONNA DO A LOT TO
WORK THAT'S PRODUCTIVE AND
REFORMING THE PROCESS AT THE
FRONT BUT A WIN AT THE END OF
THE BED AT THE BACK AND HAVEN'T
REALLY DONE ANYTHING. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THAT
QUESTION. MAYBE IT'S A BETTER
ANSWER THE QUESTION UP THOUGH
THE ROLE THAT LEGAL AFFAIRS HAS
IN THE ENTIRE PROCESS- INCLUDING
THE OVERSIGHT FOR DECISIONS MADE
BY HER. PARTY'S I'M I. WOULD
LIKE TO PASS ON. PASS IT OVER TO
LEGAL AFFAIRS CHRIS THE DONE
FILER OR- OR JENNIFER NEIL SET
MAYBE PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION.
AND ACTUALLY MAYBE IF SOMETHING
WERE GONNA SINGLE FIRST RIVER
MORE INFORMATION AND THEY CAN
HELP ME UNDERSTAND HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO MAKE SURE I HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE WARD
AND- THERE WERE. WE HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE WATER ORTON
SINCE THEY GET TO MAKE THE FINAL
DECISION. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS KRISTA THAT'S WHETHER I'M
THAT CHICK THAT THE GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE OFFICE OF LEGAL
AFFAIRS EMPLOYMENT ADVOCACY OF
PROSECUTION TEAM. I THINK I'M
SORRY CAN YOU SPEAK UP OR MAYBE
GET A LITTLE CLOSER TO THE
MICROPHONE. I WILL TRY TO MOVE
CLOSER AND SPEAK UP AT THE SAME
TIME. I CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW YES
THANK YOU. AT EIGHT I THINK THAT
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF. ISSUES
THAT YOU'VE RAISED WHERE ARE
YOUR QUESTION AND HOPEFULLY I'LL
I'LL GET. AT ALL ASPECTS
ANSWERED- FIRST WITH REGARD TO
THE OVERSIGHT- M. B. I HAVE.
WORKED WITH THE HIRING
AUTHORITIES ARE WORKING CENTER
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICERS. ON THE
HEALTHCARE SIDE. I'M PART OF
EQT'S ROLE IS TO EVALUATE THE
EVIDENCE OBTAINED DURING THE
COURSE OF AN INVESTIGATION. AND
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING
WHETHER OR NOT ALLEGATIONS OF
MISCONDUCT. SHOULD BE SUSTAINED
OR NOT. I EXISTING. WHICH WILL
CARRY OVER INTO THE NEW PROCESS
SHOULD HIRING AUTHORITY ACT IN A
MANNER THAT IS INCONSISTENT WITH
OUR POLICIES AND OUR PRACTICES.
THE ATTORNEYS AND THEIR
SUPERVISORS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ELEVATE THE HIRING AUTHORITIES
THE WARDENS OR CVS DECISION. TO
THE NEXT HIGHEST LEVEL. AND SO
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
FURTHER REVIEW AND
CONSIDERATION. OF ANY ISSUES
WHERE IT PTC'S I HAVE A DENTAL
PROBLEM WITH HELLO- WHARTON OR
CEO IS IMPOSING DISCIPLINE OR
SUSTAINING ALLEGATIONS ARE NOT
THE SAME ALLEGATIONS. I THINK
ONE OF THE OTHER BENEFITS TO
THIS NEW PROCESS AND IN TERMS OF
HELPING WITH THIS THE PLAN AND
THAT PROCESS AND WHETHER OR NOT
WATER SUSTAINING ALLEGATIONS. IS
THAT WITH MORE INFORMATION COMES
MORE CONFIDENT IN MAKING A
DECISION FOR THE HIRING
AUTHORITY FOR THE WORKING SO
BECAUSE SO MANY MORE OF THESE
CASES WILL BE INVESTIGATED THE
ONLY BE WARDENS WILL HAVE MORE
INFORMATION UPON WHICH THEY CAN
ACT. AND SO I THINK THAT THERE
WILL BE I'M ORGANISTS LIKELY
THAT THERE WILL BE A VERY
POSITIVE IMPACT ON ADDRESSING
DISCIPLINARY MATTERS AND
ADDRESSING MISCONDUCT BECAUSE
THE WARDENS AND THE CEOS WILL
HAVE ALL OF THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION. IN ORDER TO SUSTAIN
OR NOT SUSTAIN AN ALLEGATION
BECAUSE THE CASE WILL HAVE AN
INVESTIGATIVE. BY AN
INVESTIGATOR. SO I AT THIS WILL
BE MY LAST COMMENT ACTUALLY IS
NOT A QUESTION FAILING TO GIVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MY COLLEAGUES
WHO I KNOW ARE CHOMPING AT THE
BIT FOR QUESTIONS. LET ME JUST
SAY THAT HAPPY MORE INFORMATION.
IS NOT ENOUGH TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE CHANGING THE CULTURE A LOT
OF WHAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT OVER
TIME HAS BEEN ABOUT THE CULTURE
AND HE'S TO BE CHANGED. I AND SO
IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME THAT. THE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IS ENOUGH
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT AND
PROCESS- IS ACTUALLY REFORM. AS
WELL AND SO I WOULD JUST F. AS
WE MOVE TOWARDS THE MAY REVISE
SOME ADDITIONAL DETAILS THERE TO
ENSURE THAT. WE ARE- THAT THAT
WE'RE DOING GOOD WORK AT THE
FINANCE AND THE BACKEND AND BOTH
FOR THE 20% AND 80% OUT THERE
NOT JUST NOT JUST FOR SOME OUT
THERE AND SO EIGHT WHILE I
KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY'RE HAPPY
WHAT I HAVE SEEN IS AN
IMPROVEMENT FROM WE HAD SEEN
LAST YEAR I DO THINK WE NEED TO
WORK A LITTLE BIT MORE ATTENTION
AT THE THAT. THE BACK AND- IT.
IS ACTUALLY STARTING TO CHANGE
THE CULTURE AMONGST. AMONGST
INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE. AND
INFORMATION ALONE DOES NOT
CONVINCE ME THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET THERE. AND SO MISTER LUCKY.
YEAH I HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS
THAT THE- ARE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME I'M I WORK FOR
AN AGENCY THAT I ACTUALLY HAD A
COMPLAINT PROCESS AND I'VE IT'S
NOT REALLY CLEAR TO ME THAT
FIRST OF ALL MY FIRST QUESTION
WOULD BE. WENT WENT CONCERT WHEN
THE CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM-
MAKES A REFERRAL TO THE OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS. IS THEIR
CRITERIA BASED ON THE
SERIOUSNESS OF ALLEGATIONS OR
THE EVIDENTIARY. VALIDITY OF THE
COMPLAINT. THOSE ARE TWO VERY
SEPARATE. CONSIDERATIONS. THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBER FOR THAT
QUESTION SO IN OUR OLD PROCESS
WE ABSOLUTELY I USED- BEING THE
ABILITY OF EVIDENCE AS PART OF
THE CRITERIA TO SEND AN
ALLEGATION TO THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS IN OUR NEW
PROCESS WE WILL NO LONGER DO
THAT INSTEAD WE HAVE A THE WHAT
WE CALL THE ALLEGATION DECISION
INDEX IT IS A VERY. A SPECIFIC
LIST OF THE TYPES OF ALLEGATIONS
THAT NO MATTER WHAT WE'LL GO TO
THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
BASED ON THE ALLEGATION AND NOT
NECESSARILY BASED ON ANY
EVIDENCE THAT IT DOES OR DOES
NOT EXIST AT THE TIME. WE'VE
DONE THAT BECAUSE AND IDENTIFIED
THOSE TYPES OF ALLEGATIONS AS
THE MOST SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS IN
OUR DEPARTMENT AND RECOGNIZE
THAT HAVING THEM BE INVESTIGATED
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING IT'S
CRUCIAL THE POTENTIALLY
PRESERVING ANY KIND OF EVIDENCE
THAT MIGHT EXIST AND ALSO
GETTING TO THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE
MATTER AND THE TRUTH OF THE
MATTER IF YOU WELL. AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. Q. MY NEXT WOULD BE
WHAT WHEN DETERMINING A FINDING
FOR THE PARTICULAR COMPLAINT
WHAT EVIDENTIARY CRITERIA HAS TO
BE MET THERE'S A PREPONDERANCE
OF EVIDENCE. OR IS IT. NO IN OUR
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS IN ORDER TO
SUSTAIN AN ALLEGATION WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT- AND FIND IT MY LAST
QUESTION HAS TO DO IS HOW IS THE
PERCENTAGE OF CLAIMS OF THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
PLANS TO REVIEW ESTABLISHED THAT
YOU HAVE A THIRTY PERCENT. OF
THAT BASED ON YOUR MANPOWER IS
IT BASED ON SOME OTHER CRITERIA. THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
AMRIK SINGH INSPECTOR GENERAL OF
THE 30% IS A NUMBER THAT WE
DETERMINED IT WOULD BE FEASIBLE
BASED ON THE HIGH VOLUME OF-
CLEANS OR- GRIEVANCES THAT WOULD
BE RECEIVED BY THE DEPARTMENT-
WE BELIEVE THAT THIRTY PERCENT.
WOULD GIVE US A FAIR ASSESSMENT
OF THE OVERALL NUMBER OF. CLEANS
THAT WILL BE SUBMITTED-
BASICALLY 830% WE THOUGHT WAS A
REASONABLE- NUMBER FOUR STAFF TO
REVIEW IT WOULD GIVE US GREAT
INSIGHT INTO THE TOTAL NUMBER.
AND IT WOULD GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE REASONABLE
AND- RELEVANT RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE DEPARTMENT ON THEIR PROCESS
. THANK YOU. MISTER DANCER AND
THEN AS FAR AS IRIS. BUT AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS BECAUSE I'M
I'M ONE OF THE ONES. THAT REALLY
WANTED TO- PROVIDE THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL- MORE
RESOURCES- SO THAT THEY COULD
HAVE SOME OVERSIGHT- AND WE
WANTED. TO MONITOR ALL TYPES OF
CLAIMS. IT WAS THAT SIMPLE.
INSTEAD I'M LOOKING AT AN
ALPHABET SOUP OF BUREAUCRACY.
THE LITTLE LOCAL DESIGNATED
UNION LDO TO CENTRALIZE
SCREENING TEAM CST THE OFFICE OF
LEGAL AFFAIRS- LA THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS- I A THE
ALLEGATIONS INVESTIGATION UNIT
A. I. YOU AN ALLEGATION
DISSENSION INDEX A. B. I. I'M A
DEMOCRAT I WOULD EVEN WANT THIS
MUCH BUREAUCRACY IN THE PINK I
DO. HOW DO YOU GET ANYTHING
DONE. WITH THIS BUREAU MUCH
BRACKET C. AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT YOU STILL HAVE THE WARDENS
HAVING SOME IMPACT. INTO THIS
WHICH WAS THE CENTRAL PROBLEM
BEFORE. SO I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
. FIXED ANYTHING WHEN ALL THE
LIGHTS I'M LIKE YOU KNOW NOW.
ALL THE LEGISLATURE WANTED WAS
FOR THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL TO HAVE MORE MONEY
RESOURCES AND POWER. TO
OVERSIGHT THIS WHOLE
DISCIPLINARY SYSTEM THAT'S IT
WHAT YOU'VE CREATED INTERNALLY
EXACERBATE THE WHOLE PROBLEM AND
FURTHER MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT
FOR THE O. I. G. TO BE ABLE TO
DO THEIR JOB. AND SO I AGREE YOU
NEED TO GO BACK. AND FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET MORE RESOURCES TO THE
OFFICE INSPECTOR GENERAL SO THAT%
THAT INDIVIDUAL CAN DO THE JOB
TO REPORT BACK TO THIS BODY IN
THIS LEGISLATURE WHITE BEANS CAN
AND CANNOT BE DONE SO WE CAN
MAKE THE APPROPRIATE- BUDGET
RECOMMENDATIONS OR ENDORSED
LEGISLATIVE RECOMMENDATIONS. TO
HELP IMPROVE C. D. C. R. IT'S
THAT SIMPLE. ANYBODY HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THIS ALPHABET SOUP
WITH DANGER WHY THIS IS SO MUCH
BETTER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIRE BY
MAY I CAN APPRECIATE ABSOLUTELY
THEY CONCERNED WITH WITH- THE
PROCESS AND THE FACT THAT IT
DOES GO THROUGH SEVERAL
DIFFERENT STEPS IN ORDER TO BE
COMPLETED BUT I ALSO CAN TELL
YOU IN IN LOOKING AT OUR PROCESS
AND WORKING THROUGH IT FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. THAT WHAT WE'VE
SET UP NOW REALLY DOES REMOVE A
LOT OF BE. PERCEIVED OR ACTUAL
BIAS THAT EXISTED PREVIOUSLY
BECAUSE DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT
WOULD GO TO A Y. EIGHT RESTED
WITH LOCAL AUTHORITIES I BELIEVE
THAT OUR CENTRALIZED SCREENING
TEAM BEING A VERY INDEPENDENT
UNIT PART OF OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS WHEN THEY DECIDE THAT
SOMETHING IS GOING TO BE
INVESTIGATED BY THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS. THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT BURIED DIRECTLY THEN
HAND IT OFF TO THEIR PARTNERS IN
THE INVESTIGATION UNIT. AND THE
OTHER THING THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
ADD IS THAT IN ADDITION TO THE
CHANGES. IN OUR PROCESS WE ARE
ALSO WE HAVE ALSO STOOD UP ONE
CENTRALIZED DATABASE THAT TRACKS
EVERY SINGLE ALLEGATION OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT FROM THE TIME THAT
IT'S MADE ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THE COMPLETION. OF ANY
DISCIPLINE AND IF IT IF
DISCIPLINE IS TAKEN AND SO WE
WILL NOW HAVE THE ABILITY TO
STATEWIDE EVALUATE THAT DATA.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO USE THAT
DATA TO ESTABLISH WHAT WE ARE
REFERRING TO AS AN EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM. SO THAT ANY KIND OF
CONCERNING TRENDS OUR SITUATION
WHETHER IT'S A STAFF MEMBER WITH
THE PARTICULARLY YOU KNOW
NUMEROUS NUMBER OF ALLEGATIONS A
LOCATION THAT HAS A LARGE NUMBER
OF ALLEGATIONS WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE. WE'LL BE ABLE TO SEE IT
EARLY WILL BE ABLE TO ADDRESS IT
EARLY- AND GET. GET PROCESSES IN
PLACE TO IDENTIFY AND FIX WHAT'S
WRONG SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE NEW PROCESS HAT WE'VE
SET UP AND WE REALLY FEEL LIKE
THIS IS GOING TO ESTABLISH A
MUCH. BETTER PROCESS THAT WILL
IMPROVE TRANSFER CURRENCY AND
IMPROVE THE CARE. IN OUR AGE. SO
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT AND
DEFERENCE- I HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
THE O. I. G. AND IF YOU WANT TO
PUT IN THIS SET SYSTEM WHICH IS
MORE LIKE IN ALICE'S PARALYSIS.
YOU'RE GOING TO NEED SOMEBODY'S
GONNA BE ABLE TO LOOK AT WHAT
YOU'RE DOING EVALUATED HONESTLY
NOT PART OF THE SYSTEM. YOU HAVE
AN OFFICE INSPECTOR GENERAL AND
YOU CREATED. A CENTRALIZED
SCREENING TEAM TO WATCH THE
OFFICE INSPECTOR GENERAL WHEN
YOU ALSO HAVE AN OFFICE-
INTERNAL AFFAIRS. I'M SO
CONFUSED. HOW ARE YOU EVER GOING
TO GET ANYTHING DONE WITH THIS
MANY LAYERS AND SO I AM BACK TO
ALL WE NEEDED WAS TO BOLSTER THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL WE
CAN TRY THIS BUT WE STILL NEED
THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
TO TELL YOU TELL US HOW YOU
REALLY DOING THAT HOW YOU COME
BACK TO US AND TELL US HOW YOU
PERCEIVE YOUR DOING BUT HOW IT'S
REALLY DONE AND YOU NEED TO
HAVEN'T SOMEONE LOOKING AT YOU
HONESTLY AND OPENLY TO GIVE US
THE INFORMATION THAT WE NEED
HERE. THANK. AT OUR SHARE ALLEN
MY CONCERNS WITH MY WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LOS ANGELES IN
THE CHAIR AND THAT THIS IS THE
FOR ME IT SEEMS ANYTHING BUT
SIMPLE A WE'RE LOOKING FOR
STREAMLINED TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I AM NOT
CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET THERE SERVE YOU'RE
CONFIDENT- I'LL TAKE YOUR WORD
ON IT FOR NOW BUT I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO WANT TO SEE. TRUE
ACCOUNTABILITY- FOR BUT FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL CLARITY I KEEP ON
HEARING THIS WHAT IS THAT THE
NEXT LEVEL UNTIL THE NEXT LEVEL
I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE
NEXT LEVEL MEANS. I'M SORRY-
THAT THAT ANY MILLER I I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THE NEXT LEVEL GAMES
EITHER. WE'RE ALL CONFUSED. UP
THROUGH TO JUST FALL THIS
LINEAGE HERE IF THERE IS WHETHER
IT IS IN- DURING OUR AN AUDITING
OF A REVIEW OF THE STAFF
COMPLAINTS OR THE STAFF
MISCONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS. I'M
ONE SOMETHING IS IDENTIFIED-
ULTIMATELY THE WARD AND MAKES A
DECISION- BUT I KEEP ON GETTING
THIS- WORD SALAD OF- THE NEXT
LEVEL AND I JUST I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AYE I BELIEVE I
UNDERSTAND NOW WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING. SO WHEN THE HIRING
AUTHORITY HAS THE ABILITY TO
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT TO SUSTAIN ALLEGATIONS OF
MISCONDUCT. IF DURING THAT
PROCESS- AND IFIT'S BEING
MONITORED BY THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL OR IF IT'S A-
HAS. OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS
MONITORING THE CASE IF THEY
DISAGREE WITH THAT DECISION
BEING MADE BY THE HIRING
AUTHORITY THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ELEVATE IT. TO THAT NEXT ARE
THAT BAD SUPERVISOR IF YOU WILL
TO THE HIRING AUTHORITIES SO IN
THIS CASE IT'S OFTEN ELEVATED TO
AN ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR WITH THE
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
WHICH IS WHO SUPERVISES THE
WARDENS. AND THEN ON THE LEGAL
AFFAIRS SIDE THEY ALSO ELEVATED
UP TO THEIR SUPERVISOR. TO
REEVALUATE THE CASE AND TO
DETERMINE IF THE DECISIONS THAT
WERE MADE WERE APPROPRIATE OR
THE DECISION SHOULD BE CHANGED
WE CALLED EXECUTIVE REVIEW- AND
SO THAT'S THAT THE PROCESS THAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE. TO WHEN. WHEN
A CASE THAT WHEN A DECISION MADE
BY HER AND THE FORTY. ODD IS NOT
MUTUALLY. AGREED TO AMONG THOSE
MONITORING THE PROCESS. OKAY SO
A LITTLE MORE CLARITY THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME. I MEAN I GUESS I
WOULD SAY THIS IS THAT YOU HAVE
A COMMITTEE THAT SKEPTICAL OF
CREATING MORE LEVELS WITHIN AN
AGENCY THAT WE'VE LOST TRUST AND
TO MONITOR AND GET THIS RIGHT
AND CHANGE THE CULTURE AND SO
DOES HE KEEP HEARING QUESTIONS
AND DOUBTS AND US AND I THINK
THE QUESTION COMES DOWN TO WHY
CREATE A LEGAL AFFAIRS WITHIN
THE AGENCY VERSUS JUST HANDING
STUFF OVER TO THE I. O. G. AND
SO EVEN IF YOU DON'T ANSWER THAT
AS YOU. AS YOU APPROACH THEM A
REVISED I THINK YOU SHOULD BE
AWARE THAT THAT'S WITH COFFEE
RUNNING THROUGH OUR HEAD- AND SO
YOU'RE WELCOME TO SPEAK NOW
ORGAN MAY COME BACK AT AND WE
CAN ONCE THE NEXT ITEM BUT THAT
I DID FLOOR STARTING TO RUN IN
CIRCLES BUT I THINK I SUMMARIZED
MY PROVIDING THE CIRCLES ARE.
THE MAN CARE. MMHM YES MA'AM FOR
A MOMENT HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
NEAL AND ASSISTANT SECRETARY
LEGAL AFFAIRS AND CHIEF COUNSEL.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
AND WE HAVE DIFFERENT ROLES
BETWEEN IN HOUSE COUNSEL FOR THE
OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS SERVES
AS LEGAL COUNSEL. FOR THE
AGENCIES EXECUTIVES ITS
EMPLOYEES. AND NOT PROSECUTING
STAFF MISCONDUCT INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS AN
OVERSIGHT ROLE OVER THE
DEPARTMENT AND MONITOR CERTAIN
ASPECTS OF. OUR INVESTIGATIONS
AND DISCIPLINE SO WE DO SERVE
TWO DIFFERENT ROLES WITHIN THE
PROCESS. I GET THAT WERE JUST
SAYING WHY ARE WE NOT HANDING
OVER MORE INVESTIGATION POWER TO
THE O. I. G. BECAUSE WE'VE LOST
FAITH THAT AND IN THIS
DEPARTMENT AND ADDING EXTRA
LAYER SOMETHING CONVINCED US YET
SO THAT'S- THAT'S THE LITANY OF
QUESTIONS ARE GETTING AT THE END
OF THE DAY. SO WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON SAID I WANT TO
CONTINUE IN. AND THE ORDER AND
THE AGE AND THEN YOU COULD JUST
GO ONE AFTER ANOTHER AND NOW
WAIT FOR MY PROMPT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MARIE THING INSPECTOR
GENERAL FOR THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
MEDICAL INSPECTION UNIT- D.
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
IS- GIVEN THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
OBJECTIVELY- ARE. CLINICALLY
APPROPRIATELY AND METRIC OR
INTENT WE PROVIDE AN INSPECTION
PROGRAM TO REVIEW THE DELIVERY
OF THE MEDICAL CARE THE AGE
PRESENT OUR MEDICAL INSPECTIONS
CURRENTLY ARE A THREE TO THREE
AND A HALF YEAR CYCLE. AND WE
ARE REQUESTING AN R. PROPOSAL AN
ADDITIONAL- FUNDING AMOUNTS TO
HIRE EIGHTEEN POSITIONS THESE
POSITIONS WILL HELP OUR CREATE-
HELP US CONDUCT OUR CYCLES IN A
QUICKER FASHION OUR OUR MEDICAL
INSPECTION UNIT CURRENTLY
COLLECTS DATA- FROM THE
INSTITUTIONS AND WITH THAT DATA
WE CREATE A SAMPLE. THEN CONDUCT
CLINICAL CASE REVIEWS SHOULD
ENSURE THAT CARE IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS WE
ALSO CONDUCT COMPLIANCE REVIEW
OF DOCUMENTATION- TO ENSURE THE
CARE IS CONSISTENT WITH
DEPARTMENT POLICY WE CONDUCT ON
SITE TESTING AND THE PROVISION
OF CARE AND THEN WE TAKE ALL OF
THIS INFORMATION WE REVIEW IT
ENSURE ACCURACY AND WRITE
REPORTS. SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN SINCE THE MEDICAL
INSPECTION UNIT DI CAME INTO
BEING ON THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF CHANGES IN THE MEDICAL
CARE THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED AT THE
INSTITUTIONAL LEVEL THEY HAVE
INCREASED A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS
SUCH AS THERE ARE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE PROGRAMS. I HEPATITIS C.
PROGRAMS. THERE'S BEEN SOME-
TELEHEALTH TELL US HEALTH
TELLING. IMPLEMENT AND THEREFORE
WE ARE ASKING FOR THESE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS SO THAT WE
CAN CREATE- WE CAN. CONDUCT OUR
MEDICAL INSPECTIONS IN A QUICKER
FASHION AND BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
REPORTS FOR THE STAKEHOLDERS I
HAVE MUCH MORE QUICKLY IN TWO
YEARS AND NOT THREE TO THREE AND
A HALF YEARS. OUR PROPOSAL AIMS
TO BASICALLY ACHIEVE THREE
THINGS TO CREATE AN APPROPRIATE
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE BY HAVING A
NURSING SUPERVISOR ADDED.
ACCIDENT UP TO SPEED UP OUR
INSPECTION CYCLE AND THEN
PROPERLY ALIGNED STAFF WHO
REVIEW THIS COMPLEX DATA- SORT
THROUGH THE DATA AND CREATE OUR
SAMPLES. AND BASED ON THAT THIS
WE ARE ASKING FOR I BELIEVE OUR
EIGHTEEN POSITIONS- OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS. TO SPEED UP THIS PROCESS
AND I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IN REGARDS TO OUR
PROPOSAL. GREETINGS MADAM CHAIR
OF ORLANDO WITH THE L. A- WE DID
NOT RAISE ANY CONCERNS ON THIS
PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME. AT THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I HAVE
A QUESTION. I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE POSITIONS THAT ARE BEING PUT
FORTH ARE PERMANENT BUT THE
FUNDING THAT'S OFFICE ONLY FOR
THREE YEARS SINCE THE WAR THAT
THAT DECISION COME FROM TO ONLY
FUNDED FOR THREE YEARS. IS THAT
THE ORIGINAL OR IDEAS FOR BOTH-OF US THAT YOUR PROPOSAL AND I'M
ASKING THIS I'M WORRIED ABOUT
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO HIRE
AND- RETAIN PROFESSIONALS WHEN
THEY KNOW THAT THE FUNDING THIS
LIMITED. A BRAND COULD BE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
MINISTRATION CONSIDERS EACH
PROPOSAL IN ITS UNIQUE CONTACTS
AND BASED ON THE DATA SAID
AVAILABLE- WITH THE SPECIFIC
REQUEST IT WAS BASED ON DATA
COLLECTED FOR ROUGHLY A THIRD OF
THE- INSPECTIONS FOR A
RELATIVELY SMALL SAMPLE SIZE OF.
A THIRTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR THIRTY
FIVE INSTITUTIONS AND COUPLED
WITH THE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH CONDUCTING MEDICAL
INSPECTIONS ARE RELEASING
REPORTS THEY'RE IN THE MIDST. OF
THE PANDEMIC DEMONSTRATION FOUND
THAT- IT IS THAT IT WAS
APPROPRIATE ON A LIMITED TERM
BASIS TO FUND AT THE POSITIONS
FOR THREE YEARS UNTIL A MORE
COMPLETE DATA CENTERS BAILABLE.
THIS IS ALICE HEWITT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST TO
STATE THAT THIS IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL AND SO
INSPECTOR GENERAL SAYING. AS
WELL CAN SPEAK TO THIS BUT IT
WAS ESSENTIALLY WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM WHICH IS
SPEEDING UP THE MEDICAL
INSPECTION CYCLE WE JUST DON'T
HAVE A GREAT DAY TO SET TO DO IT
AND SO THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES IN THE NEAR TERM. AND
THE ADMINISTRATION'S ULTIMATELY
COMMITTED BUT THE- I TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THIS AS WELL. THE
ORANGE YOUR COMMENT BEFORE MY
NEXT QUESTION. YES THANK YOU UP
IT IS ACCURATE THIS THIS
PROPOSAL IS BASED ON ONLY TWELVE
INSPECTION- WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
CYCLE SIX AND WE ARE WE ARE NOT
COMPLETE WITHOUT CYCLE AND SO
THE DATA WE WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE
WAS LIMITED IN FASHION I WE ARE
WE ARE. HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO- HIRED THESE
PROFESSIONAL CLASSIFICATIONS OF
POSITIONS THE POSITION OF
AUTHORITY IS- FOR PERMANENT
POSITIONS IT'S JUST THE FUNDING
THAT IS LIMITED I WE WILL LIKELY
SUBMIT A FUTURE PROPOSAL I WANT
TO BE ABLE TO BUY. AS RIGHT AWAY
WITH A AND- GET THAT ADDITIONAL
DATA THAT'S NECESSARY. SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT DATA MIGHT BE
LIMITED BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE AT THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE
IS HAVING A HARD TIME IN HIRING
PHYSICIANS AND NURSES ARE READY-
AND IF I AM A PROFESSIONAL AND
WHILE THE POSITION IS PERMANENT
BUT I ALSO KNOW THERE'S ONLY
FUNDING FOR THREE YEARS AT THIS
NOT FEEL VERY PERMANENT ARE VERY
STABLE- AND SO IT SEEMS COUNTER
INTUITIVE. TO OUR LONG TERM
GOALS TO HAVE A STABLE SYSTEM
AND GET OUT OF RECEIVERSHIP.
WHICH BRINGS ME TO MY NEXT
QUESTION I HAVE HARDLY HAD ANY
PRESENCE RETURNED BACK TO US AND
RETURN BACK TO EARTH. MANY IN
THE STATE- FROM THE RECEIVER.
WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN NINETY
PERCENT. OF THE SPRINKLE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS- I
BELIEVE THERE IS A SUNBURST
NINETEEN INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN TURNED BACK- FROM THAT HAVE
BEEN DELEGATED FROM FROM THE
RECEIVER TO CDCR. AND THEN HAVE
WE HAD ANY WHERE WE'VE GOT AN-
WHEN BUT THIRTY HAS BEEN-DELEGATED BACK TO STATE AND
WE'VE LOST IT AGAIN. NOT AWARE
OF OKAY THANK YOU I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE ARE
DOING INVESTMENTS THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO GET MORE OF THESE
PRESENCE OUT OF RECEIVERSHIP AND
THAT WE KEEP THEM OUT OF
RECEIVERSHIP AND SO- I DO
QUESTION ONLY HAVING FUNDING FOR
THREE YEARS FOR POSITIONS THAT
IN GENERAL IS THE HOLY BEEN
STRUGGLING TO FIT TO FILL. UP
ALONG THE WAY. COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YOU WANT
TO ADD- OKAY WE HAVE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS- I DO APPRECIATE. YOUR
TIME. YOUR TIME TO THE THAT THE
LAST PANEL WE HAD- AND THE LAST
ITEM FOR DISCUSSION AND WE DO
HAVE A FEW ITEMS FOR NON
DISCUSSION OF MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THOSE
PROPOSALS. HE TAKE THEM NOW- C.
NINE I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELS FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR- CONTINUED
DISCUSSION. WE'RE GOING TO TURN
TO PUBLIC COMMENTS. IF THERE'S
ANY ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SCENE NINE I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND MOVE. TO THE PHONES JUST A
REMINDER EACH PERSON WILL HAVE
TO ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
. THE PHONE NUMBERS TO CONNECT.
ON THE COMMITTEE IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE- IT SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN OF YOUR
STREAMING THIS HEARING JUST IN
CASE THE NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN YEAH THAT'S.
877-692-8957 NOW I'M GOING TO
GIVE THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
AGAIN AND I WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO
BE ROLLED DOWN THE ACCESS ACCESS
CODE AT THE BEGINNING IT WAS
WRONG AND SO I DO ASK YOU TO
TAKE NOTE THE CORRECT THE CODE
IS ONE THREE. ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. AND WITH THAT
I'M GOING TO ASK- THE OPERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE.
HELLO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE. ZERO FIRST WE
WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I AM SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD WE- BOB GRAHAM AGREES THAT
THEY'RE NOT BILLABLE WHAT
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS MARK IN. AND
I AM- CALLING ON BEHALF OF. WELL
BOUNCE FREEDOM PROJECT. AND
FINE- WE ARE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION PROVIDING IMPORTANT
PROGRAMMING AND A MEMBER OF THE
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR THE MARK WILL
I AM CALLING REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. AFTER THAT
RESPONDING TO THE ISSUE OF
PUBLIC AND CHRISTMAS. REQUIRED
INCREASED INVESTMENT A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING LIKE
ARE WE CAN CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
INCARCERATED. PEOPLE PREPARING
FOR RELIEF. AND ENTRY INTO
REDUCE THE THREAT POPULATION
WHILE ENSURING COMMUNITY THANK
YOU AND WEALTHY. THANK. NEXT
CALLER ID NEXT LOOK. NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN.
MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
HELLO HI MY NAMES CONOR JOHNSON
I'M CALLING IN BEHALF OF THE
INSIGHT GARDEN PROGRAM WHERE I
CURRENTLY WORK AS THE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR MULE CREEK STATE
PRISON AND THE RE ENTRY MANAGER
SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
PARLIAMENTARY CANNOT COMING OUT
CAN CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS WE ARE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
PROVIDING IMPRISONED PROGRAMMING
AND REENTRY SERVICES WE'RE ALSO
MEMBER OF THE TRANSFORM IT IN
BURKE GROUP. I'M CALLING IN
REGARDS TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO CAD
THAT RESPONDING TO THE ISSUE OF
COVERT IN PRISONS REQUIRED
INCREASED INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS LIKE OURS SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
INCARCERATED PEOPLE PREPARING
FOR THE RELEASE AND RE ENTRY TO
REDUCE PRISON POPULATION WALL
DISNEY ENSURING COMMUNITY SAFETY
AND WELL. BEING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. WHY. TWENTY NINE.
HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS GRAHAM CANNOT CHILL I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SUCCESS
STORIES PROGRAM WELL I'M COACH
COORDINATOR WHICH ARE STORED
PROGRAM AND WE ARE COMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION PROVIDING
IMPRISONED PROGRAMMING AND A
MEMBER OF THE TRANSFORMATIVE
IMPRISONED WORKGROUP I'M ALSO
CALLING REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER
TWO- JUST TO ADD THAT RESPONDING
TO THE ISSUE OF COVERED
IMPRISONED REQUIRES INCREASED
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS- THAT PROVIDE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING AND
RE ENTRY OPTIONS LIKE OURS DOES
WELL SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT INCARCERATED FOLKS-
PREPARING FOR RELEASE AND RE
ENTRY AND TO REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION WHILE ENSURING
COMMUNITY SAFETY AND WELL BEING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE THIRTY
ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS KENNETH
HARTMAN AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CATALYST
FOUNDATION A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES IN
PRISON PROGRAMMING IN SIX
PRISONS I BELIEVE- AND HAS BEEN
DOING IT FOR THE PAST EIGHTEEN
YEARS- WE ARE ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE TRANSFORMATIVE IN PRISON A
WORK GROUP I'M CALLING REGARDING
ISSUE NUMBER TWO- AND ADDING
THAT THE RESPONDING TO THE ISSUE
OF HOPE IN THE PRESENCE REQUIRES
AN INCREASED INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING LIKE OURS SO WE CAN
CONTINUE SUPPORTING CURSORY
PEOPLE PREPARING FOR RELEASE AND
RE ENTRY. AND TO REDUCE THE
PRISON POPULATION WHILE ENSURING
COMMUNITY SAFETY AND WELL BEING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE.
THIRTY EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS
DEVELOP OR DEFEND THEM ORGANIZED
THERE WITH ELEVATOR FIRST CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS OF BOTH
CRITICAL RESISTANCE IN OAKLAND
I'M CALLING IN RESPONSE TO ISSUE
ONE ABOUT THE DPRK POPULATION
PROJECTIONS OVER THE PAST YEAR-
CALIFORNIA'S PRISON POPULATION
HAS DROPPED BY NEARLY 20% WE
ALSO CLOSED THE STATE ON PRESENT
BUT DESPITE THESE IMPORTANT
CHANGES THE START BUDGET HAVE
BEEN CITY TO INCREASE INCLUDING
FOURTEEN POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN PARTS ROTH SPENDING
WHICH IS NOT A BLUEPRINT FOR
CALIFORNIA FISCAL HEALTH AS A
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA THAT
INCREASED SPENDING FOR DVR DOES
NOT ALIGN WITH MY VALUES THAT I
HOPE THIS COMMITTEE WILL PUSH
BACK ON THE PROPOSAL. I'M ALSO
REALLY DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
INCLUDE A COMMITMENT TO CLOSE
ADDITIONAL STATE ON PRESIDENT
LAST YEAR THE L. A. O.
RECOMMENDED THE CLOSURE OF 5%
AND CURB CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET IS CALLING
FOR THE CLOSURE OF EIGHT
ADDITIONAL PRISONS AND FIVE
YEARS AND HAS RELEASED A REPORT
AND GO BACK ABOUT HOW TO DO THAT
SPIRES THE LEGISLATURE SMOKING
IT SAYS IT DOES SHOW PRISON
CULTURE THAN THE NAME OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PUBLIC SAFETY. AND FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY THANK YOU. A LINE
TWENTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S FAITH LEAD ON BEHALF OF
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE FOR CALIFORNIA A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
ADVANCINGJUSTICE LOS ANGELES AND
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE PROGRAMS HAVE FOCUSED ON
REDUCING RESIDENTS SYSTEM AND
PROMOTING WE INTEGRATION OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED ASIAN
AMERICANS NATIVE HAWAIIANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS BY SUPPORTING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS
ADVANCINGJUSTICE CALIFORNIA
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT WE MUST
DIVEST FROM SYSTEMS OF
INCARCERATIONS INCREASING
FUNDING TO CDCR WILL FUNNEL LATE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO PROVIDE AND
INVEST IN COMMUNITY BASED
SOLUTIONS. THAT WE ALL KNOW
TRULY KEEPTHEFAITH INCLUDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MENTAL HEALTH
CARE JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS AND.
WE INTO SEPSIS THANK YOU- LINE.
TWELVE MY NAME IS DEBBIE QUALITY
AND I'M A CALLING AS A PRIVATE
CITIZEN AND I'M JUST I
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE LEADING THE
WAY IN THE REHABILITATION PART
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION PRESIDENT NOT
THE PLACE TO PUT THE MENTALLY
ELBOW MY BROTHER HAS BEEN
MENTALLY ILL HE WAS A TEENAGER
IS THE LIVING WITH THIS FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS IT'S FORTUNATE THAT
THE PEOPLE LIVING WITH THE
FAMILY UP ALL THE TIME. THAT CAN
CARE FOR HIM I'M SURE HE WOULD
NOT LAST SIX MONTHS IN JAIL IT
WOULD PROBABLY DIE BECAUSE
SOMETIMES HE IS UNREASONABLE
WHAT HE REALLY NEEDS TO PAY FOR
UNDERSTANDING AND THAT PRISON IS
NOT THE PLACE TO PUT INDIVIDUALS
INDUCTED TO DRESS YOUR ALCOHOL
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A LOT MORE
MONEY THAN IT CURRENTLY BEING
SPENT ON ADDICTION TREATMENT. WE
NEED TO END CASH BAIL I KNOW
SOMEONE THAT INDUSTRY WILL BE
DISPLAYED THAT THEY CAN FIND
OTHER JOB PEOPLE SHOULD BE
INCARCERATED JUST BECAUSE THEY
ARE POOR PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T BEEN
CONVICTED OF A CRIME OFTEN LOSE
THEIR JOB WHEN THEY'RE SITTING
IN JAIL WAITING FOR THE TRIAL
IT'S EXTREMELY HARMFUL TO
FAMILIES. IT CAN ALSO BE. CAN
ALSO LEAD TO HOMELESSNESS. HELLO
I AM VERY THANKFUL THAT WE HAVE
MORE. PEOPLE AND I PRISONS THAN
ANY COUNTRY. IN CONCLUSION WE
NEED TO WORK ON ADDRESS THE
UNDER ISSUE WE NEED TO. SPEND A
LOT MORE KEEP. PEOPLE ARE NOT AT
RISK. BY THE AULT YEAH. THANK
YOU. ALL LINE UP FORTY. THANK
YOU COMMITTEE AND SHARE MY NAME
IS DIRECTLY CALLING ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE ESTATE WHITE
NONPROFIT WITH MORE THAN FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
AND- REBEKAH FIRST COMMENT ON
ISSUE TOO KOPEN NINETEEN
ANTIDEPRESSANTS WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO REMEMBER THAT THE
CORPORATION IS THE ONLY TRUE
SOLUTION TO THIS PANDEMIC AND
INEVITABLE FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
RESEARCH AND TRY TO PRETEND.
ADDITIONALLY WE WANT TO MENTION
AND REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
ALTHOUGH VACCINATION RATES ARE
ARE HIGHER THAN THE AVERAGE
BECAUSE THE NINETEEN CONTINUES
TO UNNECESSARILY SPREAD AND
THREATEN THE POLITICAL COMMUNITY
BECAUSE OF. UNVACCINATED STAFF
AND CONTRACTORS. ALSO IN REGARD
TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE BOTH
DISCUSS ITEMS ISSUE. CALIFORNIA
CANNOT SOLVE OR EVEN
AUTHENTICALLY BEGIN TO ADDRESS.
THE PROBLEM OF MISCONDUCT
IMPRISONED WITH MORE FUNDING AND
GO BUREAUCRACY. REGARDLESS OF
OVERSIGHT INVOLVING OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND INHERENTLY
DISCRIMINATORY AND OPPRESSIVE
SYSTEM CANNOT BE REFORMED THEIR
FUNDING TO CREATE A PROCESS TO
RESPOND TO BEHAVIOR THAT IS
OFTEN CULTURALLY INHERENT TO THE
SYSTEM ITSELF. WE MUST ADDRESS
IT BUT THE PROBLEM AFTER ROUTE
THANK YOU. A LINE OF FORTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF
KRISTOFF MEYER WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
SCRUTINY OF CONTRACTORS IN THAT
HEARING CONTRACTING OUT OF CIVIL
SERVICE WORK HAS BEEN AN ISSUE
AT P. C. R. COULD PLEASE PROTECT
EIGHT. AT HIGHLIGHTED MATURING
CONTRACTING OUT CREATE THE GAP
WHERE ACCOUNTABILITY EASILY
CALLS THROUGH THE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE
TO BOLSTER RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION WITHIN HIGH THEY
COMPETE JOB CLASSIFICATION BUT
IF YOU ARE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND WORK. A LINE OF FORTY
FIVE. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH STRAINS THERE AND A
MEMBER OF SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE SEARCH THE AREA AND THE
ORGANIZATION OF CURB
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET I APPLAUD THE
LEADERSHIP AND RESOLVE THIS
COMMITTEE HAS SHOWN IN MAKING ST
ONGE PRISON CLOSURE A REALITY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF
THIS LEADERSHIP I WAS VERY
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DID OT INCLUDE A
COMMITMENT TO CAUSE MORE AT ST
ONGE PRESENTS THIS YEAR. LAST
YEAR THE L. A. O. RECOMMENDED
THE CLOSURE OF FIVE THOUSAND
PURPOSE CALLING FOR THE CLOSURE
OF EACH ADDITIONAL PRISONS IN
FIVE YEARS AND HAS RELEASED A
RECORD AND A ROAD MAP ABOUT HOW
TO DO THAT I HEARD ALL OF YOU TO
COMMIT TO ADDITIONAL PRISON
CLOSURES IN THE NAME OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY. AND
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY IN. I ALSO
WANTED TO CALM ON THE PA.
PROJECTION PROVIDED BY CDC ARE
TODAY. YOUR AFTER YOUR
CALIFORNIANS HAD SENT THE
MESSAGE AT THE BALLOT BOX THAT
OUR PRISON SYSTEM IS OUT OF STEP
WITH OUR VISION FOR A HEALTHIER
GREENER AND MORE JUST
CALIFORNIA. LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED NUMEROUS
RESENTENCING LAWS THAT WILL SEE
THOUSANDS OF YEARS AFTER THEIR
SENTENCES. AS WE HEARD FROM CDC
ARE TODAY THIS IS NOT CURRENTLY
REFLECTED IN THE POPULATION
PROJECTIONS. INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN OUR PRISONS
THE CHOICE. CALIFORNIANS HAVE
REPEATEDLY CHOSEN THE CARD
DURATION LET'S CONTINUE THAT
TREND AND CONTINUE. TO CLOSE
PRESENCE THANK YOU. A LINE OF
FORTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ANGELINA ON AND I'M WITH
SURGE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND
THAT'S SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE. AS WE ALL KNOW IT
SCREWED HOUSING STABLE
EMPLOYMENT EDUCATION AND HEALTH
CARE THAT TRULY KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE NOT PRESENT. LAST
YEAR'S COMMITMENT TO CLOSE TO
PRISON BECAUSE HISTORIC AND
DESPERATELY NEEDED TO STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. I WAS
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR THAT
DEVELOPER CATION. AWFULLY CLOSE
LAST FALL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
MORE LEADERSHIP ON PRISON
CLOSURE FROM THIS COMMITTEE IN
THE WEEKS AND MONTHS TO COME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. ALAINA FORTY SIX.
HELLO MY NAME IS OLIVIA GLEASON
AND I'M CALLING FROM LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA AND THEM IN ADVOCATE
WITH CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET. IMPORTANT
HERE IMPORTANT HEARING BACK
TODAY AND HELD OVER THE LAST
YEAR ON THE ISSUE OF PRISON
CLOSURE- DESPITE HISTORIC
POPULATION REDUCTION AND TO
DESIGNATE DESIGNATED PRISON
CLOSURES. HE FEARED BUDGET
INCREASED TO FOURTEEN POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS ADDITIONALLY ON
THE NOTED KOBE AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY FIFTH THERE OVER FIVE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH ACTIVE CODE
CASES. AND FIVE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO AMONG STAFF.
ADDITIONALLY TWO HUNDRED FORTY
SIX INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN FIFTY
STAFF MEMBERS HAVE LOST THEIR
LIVES TO THE VIRUS IT IS EVIDENT
THAT THE MOST RECENT CALIFORNIA
STATE PRISON OUTBREAK IS BEING
FUELED BY OUR LARGELY BY COOK
OVER PROUD OVERCROWDING IN
REJECTING. HIS APPLICATION BY
CDCR STAFF. HE HAS PROVEN THAT
THEY ARE UNABLE TO KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC DESPITE
CONTINUAL FUNDING AT THIS POINT
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
CONTINUAL SPENDING. AND ANYTHING
ABOUT. WIRING ADDITIONAL AND- IS
A WASTE AND A- AND OUR MONEY AS
MUCH BY AND THAT AFTER IN IN A
IMPACT MAYBE CONTROL. LINE.
FORTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS ALEX-
CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA- AN AFFILIATED WITH
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE-
I'M CALLING BECAUSE I AM
DISMAYED TO LEARN THEIR
GOVERNMENT ECON FORGET DOUBLE
DOWN ON CARPOOL NEGATIVE RETURN
IT IT INCLUDES NO ADDITIONAL.
BECAUSE THE- BUDGET DESPITE
WIDESPREAD THAT PUT ON THE RIGHT
FISCAL WASTEFUL ENVIRONMENTAL TO
THE- I'M DEPARTMENT OPINION.
BUDGET CORPORATE TO BUILD DOLLAR
DESPITE THE STORE WAS IN OUR
STATE COULDN'T POPULATE-
COMMITTEE TO SHOW BOTH REDUCE BY
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE INTERESTED
QUEST BECAUSE WHEN WE BEGIN TO
MONEY OFF BECAUSE PPL AND PUT IT
INTO LAW OF FROM AND- WILL BE
TRULY BUILDING WILL KEEP
CHECKING IN PLAY THANK YOU FOR
THE. NINE FIFTY FOUR. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES YES MY NAME. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS MEGAN TOWARD AND
I'M ON THE OF CHURCH THEY- AND
I'M CALLING TODAY- LIKE THE
PREVIOUS TO REQUEST THAT YOU
THOUGHT THE CONTINUE. REYES OF
BUDGET AND REALLY. WHERE THESE
RESOURCES ARE GOING- LIKE THE
OTHERS SPEAKERS I THINK THAT WE
ARE SEEING WORSE AND WORSE-
HEALTH CONDITION- COME TO THE
FORE IN OUR STATE PRINT THEM-
BUT- ONLY BEEN MAGNIFIED BY
CLOTHING- WE'VE SEEN HORRIBLE
HOW OUTBREAKS AND MANY PEOPLE
DYING THE OUTBREAKS ARE
CONTINUING. BUT THIS IS A PART
OF THE PROBLEM THAT PRE EXISTED
THE OF THE PANDEMIC- TRICKED OUT
JUST PUBLISHED AN INCREDIBLE
ARTICLE ABOUT YEARS OF ARSENIC
POISONING AT KERN VALLEY STATE
PRISON. BOB THIS IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE- WE AS CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ARE FUNDING- THE
POISONING OF OUR FELLOW CITIZENS
AND THIS HAS THE STOCK THOUGH
LIKE THE OTHERS- HAVE SPOKEN
BEFORE ME I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE COMMITTEE- SPEAK UP FOR MORE
PRISON CLOSURE AND FOR
ALLOCATING RESOURCES TO
COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH CARE- INSTEAD OF.
FUNDING. PUTTING PEOPLE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. BLIND. FIFTY SIX.
MY NAME IS HIGHEST ONE EITHER HI
I'M A CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR
WIENER'S AND I AM A MEMBER OF
THIRD AREA. I'M CALLING ABOUT
ISSUE TWO ON YOUR AGENDA BECAUSE
CURRENT OUTBREAKS OF COBIT IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS MAKE ME THINK
OF MY FATHER. I'M THE ADOPTED
DAUGHTER OF THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PERSON. AND IF MY
FATHER HAD ENTERED THE CURRENT
CONDITIONS I MIGHT NOT ABOUT A
FATHER AT ALL SO FOR THAT AND
OTHER REASONS. IN PRISONS ALL
I'LL EVER BE ABLE TO SEE IS
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD RETURN TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES SO THEY CAN
BUILD SET FOR THEIR KIDS DANCE
PERFORMANCES AND COACH PEEWEE
SOCCER AND THE HOUSE AND THE
FAMILY AND LIFE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO THIS COMMITTEE FOR DOING
THE CRUCIAL AND HARD WORK OF
HOLDING HEARINGS ON THESE ISSUES
. I BELIEVE INVESTMENT FROM ALL
SYSTEMS OF INCARCERATION AND WE
INVESTMENT IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE JOB
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND OTHER
ELEMENTS OF BOTH FACED HEALTHY
COMMUNITY. I ASK YOU TO CLOSE
ALL PRESENT STARTING WITH THE
FACILITIES IDENTIFIED BY CURB
THANK YOU. LINE. FIFTY SEVEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNY POLITANO
NUMBER OF STURGEON BAY AREA AND
I'M CALLING FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY
WHERE I'M A CONSTITUENT OF MIA
BONTA AND SENATOR SKINNER.
PRISONS ARE A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS THAT IS WHY WE NEED
PEOPLE TO PLAN FOR PRISON
CLOSURE CALIFORNIA MUST CLOSE
TOXIC PRISONS AND CAPTURE
BILLIONS IN COST SAVINGS TO
CREATE COMMUNITY BASED SYSTEMS
OF CARE. AS WELL AS JOBS THAT
HELP BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE AND
LIFTING THE VISION FOR A
STRONGER CALIFORNIA. THE BUDGET
SHOULD REVEAL WAT WE TRULY
VALUE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED-
INCREASES IN PERSONAL SPENDING
DO NOT REFLECT MY VALUES I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR LEADERSHIP TO
ENSURE THAT WE END UP WITH A
BUDGET THAT REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA'S DESIRE FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE. ECONOMIC JUSTICE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH BY CLOSING PRISONS AND
INVESTING INSTEAD IN OUR
COMMUNITY. A BUDGET THAT
PRIORITIZES THE INCARCERATION OF
OUR MOST VALUABLE OF VULNERABLE
AND MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS
DOES NOT. REFLECT MY VALUES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. ALAINA
FIFTY EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE AND FORMER I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF REVOLUTION GEN WE
ARE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THE PRICE
INCREASE IN PROGRAMMING ARE ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE TRANSFORMATIVE
IMPRISONED WORKGROUP I'M CALLING
IN RESPONSE TO AND NUMBER TWO-
AND JUST ASKING THAT WE ADDED-
THAT RESPONDING TO THE- IT
SHOULD BE COVERED IN PRISON.
REQUIRES INCREASED INVESTMENT.
IN THE U. S. ORGANIZATION WHAT
WE DO PROVIDE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING LIKE ARE TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT INCARCERATED PEOPLE
FOR THE PREPARE FOR RELEASE IN
REENTRY IT CAN HELP KEEP THAT
PRISON POPULATION PREDICTABLE.
BROWN PERFORATED BOX OFFICE AND
STAFF ALIKE SAFER. I CAN REDUCE
THE PRISON POPULATION. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND I APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR DOING. AND WE HAVE NO
MORE PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. OKAY I THANK YOU MODERATOR
WHEN I THINK. THE PANELISTS- THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF STAFF AND
ALSO ALL THE PUBLIC COMMENT. OF
THAT MEETING TO BE HERE WITH US
TODAY AND WITH THAT WE WILL
RETURN TO THE HEARING.